la parole est à monsieur serge letchimy
monsieur le premier ministre que la mort
de georges floyd a soulevé l'indignation
de milliers de personnes dans le monde
entier
elle met en relief le racisme vertébrale
les états unis première puissance
mondiale dans les germes proviennent
principalement de l'esclavagé des noirs
les nations d'occident elles aussi se
sont enrichis sous ces mêmes fondations
ce sont ces fondations qui ont créé et
maintenu vivace dans le monde
contemporain leurs assises que l'action
politique ne saurait tolérer
oui contre toutes les violences raciales
la république se doit d'être exemplaire
exemplaires sur l'exigence de justice de
vérité face aux drames humains répéter
comme celui d'amada traoré le racisme
peut être aussi obscur et larvée par la
présence inacceptables de certains
monuments symboles de la période
coloniale
ici à l'assemblée nationale je pense à
colbert le père du code noir par la
parole de celui qui à longueur de
tribunes et d'antennes distille
impunément la paix ce qui lui sert
d'activité mental je veux parler d'eric
zemmour c'est tout cela qui fait
persister un esprit colonial érigés en
système
source d'inégalité d'injustice de
génération en génération
c'est cet esprit colonial qui attisent
des révoltes qui font entendre et qui
exige des mesures exceptionnelles
l'outre-mer est au coeur de ce drame
pose coloniale et justice au quotidien
asphyxie dans la dépendance structurelle
à la tête des administrations dans
l'économie dans les niveaux
d'équipements de santé d'éducation et de
culture dont le traitement des scandales
comme ceux de la chlordécone et j'en
passe la vague planétaire qu'a suscité l
assassinat de floride montrent que la
dépréciation d'une minorité humaine ne
sera plus accepté mais je le bois est
miss il est encore temps de donner un
sens à ce principe majeur de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen les hommes naissent et demeurent
libres et égaux en droits c'est en
mettant fin au racisme que nous pouvons
dépasser les sur le histoire réparer des
fractures du présent et regarder
l'avenir en confiance quand
accepterez-vous enfin d'oxygéner ce pays
merci monsieur le député la parole est
un monsieur christophe castaner ministre
de l'intérieur merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député serge letchimy nous
partageons une convection le racisme
constitue une plaie le racisme constitue
une plaie ouverte dans notre pacte
républicain
le racisme n'est pas une opinion le
racisme est un délit leur assise mérite
la mobilisation de chacune et chacun
d'entre nous constamment parce que c'est
une vigilance et c'est une lumière qui
implique que nous protégions cette
lumière le racisme doit se voir à l'aune
de la réalité de nos territoires et en
particulier en outre-mer et vous savez
particulièrement pourquoi vous évoquez
cela par rapport à cette histoire mais
c'est notre histoire c'est l'histoire de
la république française qui a ses parts
de lumière extraordinaire mais qui a
aussi ses parts d'ombrés que nous devons
monsieur le député vous avez raison
regardez en face parce que tout l'enjeu
de l'émotion mondiale que nous
connaissons suite au décès de georges
floyd c'est d'avoir la capacité
justement à regarder la réalité en face
à ne jamais la cacher cette qualité à ne
jamais la trahir parce que qui veut la
terre l'a trahi
au fond cette réalité il y a notre
histoire il y à cette part de lumière il
ya cette part d'ombré mais ça n'est pas
en des boulots non ça n'est pas en
abattant des statuts
ça n'est pas en dénonçant et en
cherchant à opposer les uns et les
autres que nous arriverons à vaincre le
racisme c'est plutôt construisant cette
société apaisée cette société monsieur
le député qui osent regarder dans les
yeux sa propre histoire et ce n'est pas
toujours facile il a fallu sur la
seconde guerre mondiale par exemple que
le temps passe et que l'âge des
présidents le permettent
or le racisme est quelque chose qui nous
touche dans notre histoire qui nous
touche dans notre quotidien et pour
lequel nous devons être totalement
mobilisée et c'est le cas du plan
d'action que le premier ministre avait
présenté en 2018 avec toute une série de
mesures pour lutter contre la
discrimination et c'est le cas monsieur
le député
du combat permanent que nous menons et
que je mène
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame valérie la croûte
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
c'est non sans une certaine émotion que
je m'adresse à vous pour la dernière
fois après avoir été élu maire de la
très jolie ville de nemours huit années
a siégé huit années à siéger sur les
bancs de l'opposition à défendre sans
beaucoup de succès il faut le dire des
amendements jusqu'à point d'heure à
écouter les réponses des ministres dicté
par la haute administration à porter des
dossiers de la circonscription dont
certains n'ont toujours pas abouti
je pense à la reconstruction du
commissariat de fontainebleau qui attend
encore un engagement concret du ministre
de l'intérieur
ce qui m'amène une nouvelle fois au nom
du groupe l'est républicain adresser
notre plein soutien aux forces de
l'ordre pour ce bilan pour ce bilan
peut-être modeste j'ai la conviction
d'avoir défendu laisser les marnais avec
force et détermination
cette introspection le président de la
république devrait également se
l'appliquer car dimanche nous avons
assisté à un véritable satisfecit d'un
président déjà en campagne pour 2022 qui
fait table rase des rapts et de la crise
manque de masse manque de tests avant
dans nos aînés dans les ehpad 1
cohérence territoriale dans les
décisions des protocoles sanitaires
inapplicable la situation économique du
pays est dramatique
le président de la république multiplie
désormais les annonces alors qu'il
faisait encore la sourde oreille sur les
difficultés majeures que rencontrait le
personnel soignant
bien avant la crise sanitaire les
négociations traînent et les soignants
sont une nouvelle fois dans la rue
le déni est telle que le président de la
république ose même le chantage auprès
des présidents de région
des aides financières contre le report
des élections régionales
jusqu'où ira-t-on alors monsieur le
premier ministre vous qui avait siégé
sur les bancs de la droite et même à mes
côtés pensez vous que ce nouveau monde
est vraiment à la hauteur des enjeux
colossaux de notre pays
merci chers collègues et tous nos
félicitations pour votre brillante
élection et tous nos voeux de succès à
la tête de la commune de nemours
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame madame
la députée permettez moi pour commencer
à vous répondre de vous féliciter pour
votre élection municipale a le mot vous
féliciter chaleureusement pour cette
dernière question vous poser dans cet
hémicycle où vous l'avez rappelé ou où
vous l'avez rappelé madame la députée
nous avons lors de notre première séance
dans cet hémicycle siéger et côte à côte
un peu plus haut là au fond
communaux et je veux dire madame la
députée que quels que soient les choix
que vous et moi avons fait est que vous
et moi
assumons j'ai un souvenir ému et
beaucoup d'affection et de respect pour
vous avez dans votre question madame la
députée j'ai quand même le droit de dire
à madame la députée que pendant cinq ans
nous avons siégé ensemble et que j'en
conserve un excellent souvenir
vous avez évoqué vous avez évoqué madame
la députée la situation locale mais
importante du commissariat de
fontainebleau vous l'avez évoqué avec
moi le maire de fontainebleau frédéric
valletoux l'a également évoqué avec moi
c'est un sujet que le ministre de
l'intérieur suit avec attention et
j'espère parce que comme vous je suis
impatient j'espère que nous pourrons
trouver la bonne solution
vous avez profité de cette question
locale importante pour formuler votre
soutien aux forces de l'ordre
je croix madame la députée et d'une
certaine façon je m'en réjouis même si
je n'en suis pas surpris que tous ici
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
quelles que soient nos choix politiques
nous pouvons aujourd'hui parce que la
situation est difficile parce que nous
avons vu dans certaines villes de france
je pense évidemment à nice et à dijon
des images insupportables
ce ne sont pas les images qui sont
insupportables c'est la réalité qui est
insupportable
nous avons vu le rôle éminent une fois
de plus des forces de l'ordre forces de
l'ordre que nous soutenons tous et dont
nous nous disons mesdames et messieurs
les députés qu'elle serait dans les
circonstances actuelles singulièrement
démuni si elles étaient désarmées
singulièrement démuni si elles étaient
désarmées ce qui est une idée baroque
qui finalement ne peut pas prospérer
nous le savons alors madame la députée
vous formuler des critiques vives sur
l'intervention du président de la
république et je dois dire que sur ce
sujet nous ne sommes pas d'accord nous
ne sommes pas d'accord car vous faites
de la france
vous faites de la réponse publique vous
dressez de la réponse publique qui a été
apportée à la crise sanitaire et aux
conseils aux conséquences économiques de
la crise sanitaire
un tableau très noir je vous dire madame
la députée
personne ici n'a jamais nié la
difficulté de la situation que personne
dans le pays ne nie la difficulté de la
situation et que j'entends comme vous
l'entendez sans doute même si vous ne le
dites pas l'assemblée mais je suis sûr
qu'à new moore ou à fontainebleau
on vous le dit que les commerçants de
france les restaurateurs de france
l'ensemble de ceux qui ont subi les
effets de la crise sanitaire savent que
la réponse de l'état le versement des
aides la prise en compte par le chômage
partiel dans des conditions remarquables
a été à la hauteur des enjeux
je suis sûr madame la députée qu'il vous
le dis je suis sûr qu'il vous dise
je suis certain qu'il vous le disent ils
ont raison vous le dire ils ont raison
de le dire
et au fond au fond nous devrions en être
fier car sur ce point la réponse a été
remarquable pour le reste que vous ne
partagiez pas ni le constat ni la
stratégie formulée par le président de
la république je n'en suis pas surpris
ce que je sais c'est que la situation
telle que nous la vivons exige des
transformations majeures et pas un
apaisement quelconque exige que nous
puissions faire face aux dangers qui
nous menacent à l'extérieur à
l'intérieur exige que nous puissions
faire preuve d'une plus grande
solidarité vis-à-vis des plus
vulnérables exige que nous aurions tôt
notre production et notre consommation
vers des axes qui sont compatibles avec
la transition écologique tout cela le
président de la république l'a dit tout
cela il faudra le faire merci monsieur
la parole la parole à monsieur alexandre
freschi merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
ma question s'adresse à monsieur jean
michel blanquer remise de l'éducation
nationale et et de l'éducation et de la
jeunesse face à à l'inédit nos
professeurs l'éducation nationale et
l'ensemble des familles ont pris à bras
le corps cette question de la continuité
pédagogique avec efficacité le
l'enseignement à distance également a
été plébiscité par 75% des familles
preuve aussi de la qualité la capacité
d'adaptation de nos professeurs à
fournir un travail de qualité dans une
situation contrainte
oui les agents et l'institution ont été
à la hauteur durant cet événement et
nous sommes tous ici extrêmement
reconnaissants envers nos professeurs
qui ont été mobilisés fortement la
détermination de du président de la
république du premier ministre de de
vous également monsieur le premier lieu
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
aura rendu possible ce qui était
inenvisageable quelques semaines
auparavant
face à cela également saluant l'esprit
extrêmement partisi parti et
bienveillant des élus locaux qui ont
rendu possible ce moment là pour autant
nous savons que dans cette situation
être éloigné de l'école c'est aussi
risquer de voir les inégalités se
creusent et plus les élèves en
difficulté sont éloignés de l'école plus
ces inégalités risquent de se renforcer
le retour à l'école est donc nécessaire
et même indispensable alors que s'ouvre
aujourd'hui une période nouvelle une
nouvelle étape pour l'école avec un
protocole sanitaire qui nécessitent des
points de qualification
monsieur le ministre pourriez vous nous
indiquer quels sont les éléments sur
lequel repose justement ce protocole
afin de rassurer à la fois les familles
et les parents et les et professeurs qui
sont tous les jours au service de nos
élèves
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député alexandre skis merci
pour cette question qui permet de mettre
l'accent sur l'un des points les plus
importants du déconfinement dans lequel
processus dans lequel nous nous trouvons
actuellement et merci d'en avoir rappelé
l'historique puisqu'il y a eu le
confinement à partir du 15 mars jusqu'au
11 mai la décision extrêmement
courageuse du président de la république
au milieu du mois d'avril avec beaucoup
de critiques ça et là sur seul sur le
fait de descons fine et alors même
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde comprend
que c'était la bonne décision à prendre
et qu'au coeur de cette décision
il fallait le déconfinement scolaire
pour bien montrer que l'école c'est
fondamental et que c'était l'intérêt de
nos élèves d'y retourner pour le faire
pour le faire il fallait avoir un
protocole très strict et c'est ce que
nous avons fait ce protocole
parfois il a été critiqué parce
qu'effectivement il crée beaucoup de
contraintes
ces contraintes elle n'était pas là pour
le plaisir elles étaient là pour assurer
les conditions de santé
elle était là aussi pour restaurer la
confiance cette confiance elle est là
aujourd'hui elle est là parce que
désormais les parents en confiance dans
le fait d'envoyer les enfants à l'école
et l'ensemble de l'institution a
confiance en elle même est donc
aujourd'hui nous pouvons avoir un
nouveau protocole sanitaire allégé tout
simplement parce que collectivement nous
tous les français nous avons pu faire
progresser le pays
s'agissant du virus et nous avons
aujourd'hui des conditions qui nous
permette d'aller de l'avant
cet allégement du protocole sanitaire il
se traduit par plusieurs mesures mais la
principale c'est évidemment l'allègement
des conditions distanciation physique
cet allégement nous permet de pouvoir
accueillir tous les élèves nous
travaillons d'ailleurs avec les
organisations représentatifs et en lien
avec le ministère de la santé pour que
ce protocole sanitaire soient publiés
demain
ce protocole sanitaire va donc nous
permettre d'avoir le retour de tous les
enfants à l'école et au collège et aussi
d'ouvrir davantage les lycées de france
puisque nous sommes en zone verte
hormis en guyane et à mayotte et c'est
évidemment une aide une très bonne
nouvelle je suis certain que désormais
la représentation nationale sera unanime
pour célébrer ce début retour à la
normale
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur christophe bouillon merci
monsieur le président comme le dirait
eddy mitchell c'est ma dernière séance
c'est à dire ma dernière question et
j'ai pensé transformé ma question en
aveux dans l'espoir qu'il se réalise
j'ai fouillé dans ce qu'il m'a fait
bouillonner ces derniers temps et j'ai
repris la question de l'écocide et de sa
reconnaissance dans le droit pénal que
j'ai défendue au nom de mon groupe il y
quelques temps de cela l'équation est
assez simple qui dit écocide dit
criminalité environnementale qui dit
crédibilité environnementale dit
destruction d'habitats naturels qui dit
destruction d'habitats naturels dix
animaux sauvages en déshérence et qui
dit animaux sauvages en déshérence dit
risque de pandémie ou d'épidémie vous
voyez à quoi je fais référence
alors quand allez vous reconnaitre enfin
dans notre droit l'écocide un mot plus
personnel monsieur le président si je
suis ici depuis 13 ans c'est à cause de
ma mère lorsque j'étais lycéen lors de
mon premier engagement assurez vous
monsieur le premier ministre
rien de violent c'était pour la
constitution d'un comité de défense pour
nelson mandela ma mère m'avait dit la
politique ce n'est pas pour nous et
depuis ces longues d'année j'ai tout
fait pour ne pas lui donner raison
et pour faire en sorte que le fils de
marin et de femmes de ménage que je suis
est sa place ici et si j'ai beaucoup
donné parfois au détriment de mes
enfants oscar et hermann c'est pour
faire en sorte que eux ou ceux de leur
génération ne se dit jamais que la
politique ce n'est pas pour eux un
dernier mot et monsieur le ministre je
crois savoir monsieur le premier je
crois savoir que vous êtes de ces hommes
qui lisent et que vous aimez le verbe je
crois que nous avons en commun sans
doute cela est un peu la normandie aussi
j'emprunterai mémo à ce poète federico
garcia lorca qui a été abattu comme vous
savez par les miliciens
parce que homosexuels parce que
républicain sans doute parce que poète
et il disait je reviendrai ici chercher
mais elle oui je reviendrai chercher ici
mais elle parce que je suis de ceux qui
pensent que notre assemblée est capable
de nous élever
elle l'a fait lorsque notre ancien
collègue patrick roy nous a ému
jusqu'aux larmes elle l'a fait lorsque
nous avons tous ensemble entonné la
marseillaise au moment des attentats et
pour certains d'entre nous elle a fait
aussi lorsqu'elle a voté le mariage pour
tous ou la pma pour tous je suis
persuadé qu'elle le fera encore vive la
république
merci
merci chers collègues à vous aussi
nos félicitations et nos voeux de succès
dans les mandats que vous allez
continuer à exercer et nous essaierons
de continuer à nous élever dans les
termes de votre amicale recommandations
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député bouillon je ne dirais pas ça en
temps normal mais non de non vous avez
bien fait de ne pas écouter votre mère
et permettez moi de penser que même si
vous lui avaient désobéi
elle doit être sacrément fier de vous
alors après 13 ans monsieur le député
après une action aux parlementaires
complète après un engagement constant
après des responsabilités parlementaires
mais aussi des responsabilités locales
plus exactement de président d'une
association représentant les villes de
france
vous faites le choix de votre commune
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire que
c'était un choix très compréhensible et
très respectable et que vous l'avez sans
aucun doute longuement mûri je me
permets de dire puisque vous et moi
partageons un attachement pour la
normandie que il arrive que l'on dise
que chez moi dans le pays de caux on a
plutôt affaire à des taiseux et il faut
reconnaître qu'en pays qu il ya beaucoup
de taiseux vous le savez comme moi il
est bon que parfois les taiseux
s'exprime et pendant 13 ans vous avez
exprimé la voie de
vos concitoyens de ceux qui vous avez
fait confiance dans des sujets où il
partageait vos choix et peut-être aussi
monsieur le député dans des sujets où
ils les partager - mais où vous aviez au
fond la conviction que l'intérêt général
l'intérêt de la france
commandez de suivre un chemin qui
n'était peut-être pas complètement celui
de ceux qui vous avez élu sur tous les
sujets mais qui était celui que vous
croyez utile de suivre et peut-être même
à certains égards de défricher pour cela
monsieur le député je veux vous dire
mais très sincère affection
vous avez posé une question sur
l'écocide et l'honnêteté m'oblige à dire
monsieur le député que je ne suis pas
peut-être je ne suis certainement pas
pardon le plus grand spécialiste
juridique du crime déco side ça peut
venir
ça peut venir je compte sur le travail
de vos collègues pour faire mon
évangélisation si j'ose dire mais mais
je prends un engagement comme vous
l'avez pris celui de m'y mettre et de
pouvoir vous répondre très directement
et très complètement par écrit monsieur
le député merci monsieur le premier
ministre
la parole est à madame sophie auconie
qui reste parmi dont j'admire mes
collègues mais c'est avec un plaisir non
dissimulé
messieurs le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
j'ose espérer avoir votre réponse bien
que n'étant pas élu local monsieur le
premier ministre et j'associe à cette
question mon collègue meyer habib
dimanche soir le président de la
république a tenu à réaffirmer le
soutien de l'état aux forces de l'ordre
qui garantissent l'ordre républicain
c'est un message auquel évidemment
s'associent comme l'ensemble des groupes
de ce banc de ses banlieues dei et les
indépendants les policiers gens
arm exercent un métier difficile et
espère et opère pardon dans des
situations souvent complexes pour
assurer notre sécurité
l'actualité récente a profondément ému
nombre de nos concitoyens faisant naître
des craintes et des peurs à celle ci il
est indispensable d'y répondre également
c'est pourquoi il est important de
restaurer un climat de confiance tant du
côté des forces de l'ordre que des
citoyens
le gouvernement a pris des mesures sur
les modalités d'interpellations sans
pour autant donner d'alternative
ce qu'il a d'ailleurs contraint à
revenir en arrière il existe pourtant
une solution qui permettrait de
sécuriser les arrestations généraliser
le recours à la vidéo
notre crise notre collègue christophe
naegelen avait d'ailleurs rédigé un
rapport sur les missions et les moyens
des forces de l'ordre et des forces de
sécurité en mettant en avant cette
proposition notre groupe a déposé une
proposition de loi à ce sujet
de nombreux dispositifs existent comme
l'utilisation de la caméra piétons pour
la gendarmerie mobile cette proposition
réel avantage d'être protectrice pour
les haines les personnes interpellées
mais également pour les forces de
l'ordre qui ne doivent pas subir de
présomption de culpabilité
alors monsieur le premier ministre ma
question est simple allez vous équiper
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre de
caméras afin de sécuriser leurs
opérations et que comptez vous faire
pour apaiser les relations entre nos
forces de l'ordre et nos concitoyens je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée au coni vous avez
raison de souligner cet engagement parce
que nos forces de l'ordre accomplissent
un travail exceptionnel dans des
conditions toujours difficiles
chaque jour chaque nuit ils sont
mobilisés pour protéger nos concitoyens
ils sont mobilisés et pourtant subissent
trop souvent des menaces des
intimidations des représailles même
quelquefois à leur domicile
permettez moi en vous répondant
d'évoquer
la mémoire de jean baptiste salvin
jessica schneider j'étais samedi matin
avec leur famille avec leurs camarades
policiers à mantes la jolie
il ya quatre ans ils ont été assassinés
assassinés parce que policiers et
permettez-moi en évoquant évidemment cet
engagement de vous dire combien il est
essentiel pour moi et je le fais sans
cesse depuis 20 mois d'être leur premier
défenseur et j'en suis fier madame la
députée contre tous ceux contre tous
ceux qui ont sali d'outrance en les
accusant d'être des milices en les
accusant d'être des barbares on les
accuse en proposant comme l'a rappelé le
premier ministre qu'il puisse être
désarmés ou en ne réagissant pas aux
cris scandaleux du suicide et vous dont
chacun se souvient ici et je les ai
toujours entendu et je les ai toujours
défendu mais j'ai fait mieux que cela
j'ai fait mieux que criait madame la
députée j'ai fait en sorte de porter un
budget d'action depuis trois ans que ce
gouvernement est en place c'est plus
d'un milliard d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires qui ont été mobilisés
pour la sécurité intérieure depuis 10017
c'est un plan d'action de recrutement de
dix mille policiers gendarmes qui a été
engagée sur notre territoire
et puis j'ai abordé des sujets qui n'ont
jamais abordé comme le paiement des
heures supplémentaires dont certaines
étaient dus depuis 2005
voilà la réalité de notre engagement et
il faut renforcer cela et vous avez
raison madame la députée je suis
convaincu qu'un plan de généralisation
global de caméras piétons de nouvelle
génération avec de nouveaux droits pour
défendre nos policiers et nos gendarmes
est essentielle
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur bastien la chaux merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
travailler et produire davantage voilà
le monde après que le président de la
république nous a proposé dimanche soir
dans un océan d'autosatisfaction mais
eux deux ils promettaient le monde
d'après tout devait changer
et voilà que rien ne change il disait
l'économie sera sauvé quoi qu'il en
coûte
mais il fallait comprendre je vous ferai
payer les plans de soutien je vous ferai
rembourser la dette
ce n'est même plus travailler plus pour
gagner plus c'est travailler plus pour
rembourser plus travailler encore plus
longtemps
rallonger le temps de travail raccourcir
les congés payés repousser le départ à
la retraite
voilà ce que le président a annoncé
dimanche soir
absurde augmenter la durée du travail
s'est baissé les salaires et maintenir
des millions de français au chômage
c'est affaiblir la demande intérieure
est alimenté la récession
absurde produire davantage c'est nous
envoyer dans le mur de la crise
écologique produire toujours plus pour
alimenter le grand déménagement du monde
le productivisme épuise la nature et les
travailleurs il faut faire tous linverse
il faut engager la bifurcation
écologique planifier la relocalisation
des activités produire ce dont nous
avons vraiment besoin
il faut partager le temps de travail
pour que chacun est un emploi il faut
partager la richesse produite pour que
chacun puisse vivre dignement de son
travail
jamais les français n'ont été aussi
productif
jamais la france n'a été aussi riche
c'est donc possible mais vous encourager
les ultra-riches à s'accaparer toute la
richesse laissant des miettes à celles
et ceux qui la produisent
arrêtez de sous-entendre que les
français saban donnerait à la mollesse
et devrait retrouver le sens de l'effort
c'est vous qui organisez le déclin de la
france
les français ont le sens de l'effort et
du travail bien fait la bifurcation
écologique leur redonnera
un objectif à la hauteur des enjeux de
notre temps le partage du travail et des
richesses leur rendra le goût du bonheur
qu'attendez vous monsieur le premier
ministre merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur bruno le maire
-ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
lachaud
je crois qu'il n'y a pas pire sourd que
celui qui ne veut pas entendre et je
pense nous n'avons pas entendu la même
intervention du président de la
république dimanche soir notre priorité
absolue celle du prêt beneath du
président la république de toute cette
majorité c'est l'emploi vous connaissez
la situation actuelle vous voyez ce qui
nous attend et tout est fait tout a déjà
été fait avec le chômage partiel avec
les mesures de relance avec les soutiens
sectoriels pour soutenir l'emploi dans
notre pays
donc nous ne sommes pas là pour soutenir
des ultra riches ou je ne sais quelle
catégorie de notre population nous
sommes là pour que tous les français
puissent trouver un travail dans cette
période de crise économique que nous
connaissons tous nous sommes là pour
relancer notre économie et c'est ce qui
va être fait dans le débat que nous
aurons en juillet sur les mesures de
relance pour le touriste pour
l'hôtellerie pour la restauration pour
l'aéronautique pour l'industrie
automobile pour la tech pour le commerce
pour les indépendants nous sommes là
pour accélérer cette transition
écologique à laquelle vous aspirez et
laquelle nous aspirons tous ici et s'il
faut mettre de l'argent public pour
accélérer cette transition écologique
s'il faut faire une rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments s'il faut
fixer des conditions au soutien que nous
apportons aux entreprises publiques
nous le faisons nous voulons que l'art
l'on souhaite une relance verte
nous voulons que ce choix une relance
écologique nous mettons beaucoup
d'argent public c'est vrai le président
de république l'indiqué près de 500
milliards d'euros pour que notre
économie soit sauvée que les emplois
soient préservés et que nous puissions
avoir une économie plus forte
à la sortie de cette crise ça aboutit à
plus de dettes et cette dette c'est
peut-être le seul point de divergence
que nous ayons oui il faut bien la
rembourser parce que vous aurez du mal à
convaincre les investisseurs de venir en
france soutenir notre économie
si vous leur dites que l'argent vous
l'avaient emprunté vous ne le
rembourserait pas un jour nous assumons
le choix de l'endettement pour préserver
notre économie mais oui cette dette
le bon mot venu il faudra la rembourser
par la croissance est bien la liste la
parole est à monsieur jean louis
bourlanges
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
ça marche oui l'initiative
franco-allemande appelant à un transfert
budgétaire massif de l'union en
direction des états frappé par la
pandémie couronne les efforts de notre
pays pour corriger la principale
anomalies du traité de maastricht la
dissociation entre l'intégration
monétaire ambitieuse et une absence de
vraies solidarités budgétaires
elle atteste de surcroît la vitalité de
la relation franco-allemande nos
partenaires prétendu rigide auront en
disant accepter à notre appel
trois choses qui n'avaient pas
initialement leur faveur la politique de
rachat par la bce des dettes souscrites
par les états fragiles
la reconnaissance par le tfc j'ai du
lien nécessaire entre le niveau de
rigueur budgétaire et l'état de la
conjoncture économique est déjà été
désormais la mise en place de transferts
budgétaires massifs de solidarité le
conseil européen doit maintenant
répondre à deux questions essentielles
côté dépenses le gouvernement peut-il
nous faire part des clés terres sur
lesquelles à ses yeux la répartition
entre les prêts et les transferts
devrait s'opérer
côté ressources peut-il nous dire si et
dans quelle mesure le plan doit être
financés par une contribution des états
proportionnelle à leur richesse ou ce
que nous préférons par le recours
vail ressources propres et dans ce
dernier cas laquelle cette initiative
est cependant guetté par l'enlisement
dans le marécage procédurales des
décisions à l'unanimité et des
ratifications obligatoires
ne pensez vous pas qu elle devra
impérativement déboucher sur un saut
qualitatif d'ordre institutionnel
l'extension à certains aspects du
domaine budgétaire et fiscale du vote à
la majorité qualifiée et de la
codécision conseil parlement le moment
n'est-il pas venu monsieur le premier
ministre pour la france
d'inviter les européens à revisiter sort
à point essentiel le pacte
institutionnel qui les unit merci chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés et monsieur le
député il ya quelques semaines au sénat
j'avais eu l'occasion pendant le
confinement j'avais eu l'occasion de
dire ce que je crois beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ressentent et dans le début
de la crise sanitaire et dans la réponse
qui était apportée que l'union
européenne n'avait peut-être pas été
dans l'immédiateté de la crise là où
nous l'espérions
là où nous l'attendions et ce sentiment
partagé en france en italie en espagne
par de nombreux partisans fervent
convaincu de l'europe nous désole et
nous inquiéter depuis il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses car justement ces
fervents partisans ceux qui savent que
l'avenir de notre continent passe par
une structuration politique et
économique de l'europe cela se sont
ressaisis et ils s'en sont ils se sont
ressaisis monsieur le député vous
l'avais dit à juste titre grâce au
couple franco allemand
grâce à cette capacité qu'ont eu les
dirigeants français président de la
république
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
mobilisés sur ce sujet et les dirigeants
allemands au premier chef d' entre la
chancelière merkel de s'entendre et de
rappeler que
l'europe n'avance est jamais aussi bien
que quand son moteur franco allemand ce
qui n'est pas toujours acceptée par nos
autres partenaires
en tout cas pas cette formulation
s'entendait et essayer de faire des
propositions qui permettait d'entraîner
de passer une étape
la proposition de la commission
européenne
la proposition de budget et la
proposition de plan de relance s'inspire
vous le savez beaucoup de ce travail
franco allemand qui a été formulée
publiquement la proposition de la
commission qui doit être discuté c'est
un peu plus de 1800 milliards d'euros
c'est une somme considérable et beaucoup
d'entre nous ont parfois du mal à se
représenter ce que cela peut vouloir
dire que 1800 milliards d'euros c'est
une réponse à la hauteur des enjeux
elle comporte une partie destinée à la
relance et une autre qui est plus
classique qui est destiné au budget de
l'union pour la période 2021 et 2027
les négociations autour de ce plan vont
s'engager lors du conseil européen de
vendredi sur les ressources
vous avez posé cette question la france
est favorable à ce que le budget
européen soit financée par de nouvelles
ressources propres
certaines ont fait l'objet de
propositions opérationnelles par la
commission elle devrait être mise en
oeuvre dès 2021 vous les connaissez
c'est le cas de la taxe plastique c'est
le cas des ressources dites ets
c'est-à-dire qu'ils taxent les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'autres vont
faire l'objet de discussions et nous
pensons qu'il convient d'accélérer leur
mise en oeuvre
c'est la taxe numérique sur laquelle
nous nous sommes beaucoup battus c'est
la taxe carbone aux frontières qui est
essentiel si on veut remettre une forme
d'équité dans le commerce international
et prendre en compte les objectifs de
l'accord de paris c'est la taxe sur les
transactions financières dont il nous
semble qu'elle ne peut être mise en
place
utilement qu'à l'échelle européenne et
pas simplement état par état
côté dépenses puisque vous avez évoqué
aussi la question des dépenses la
commission vous le savez a proposé la
création d'un instrument financier à
hauteur de 750 milliards d'euros destiné
à réhausser pendant trois ans les
programmes de l'union ces 500 milliards
d'euros de dépenser 250 milliards
d'euros de prêts autour de trois piliers
la facilité de relance et de résilience
et 560 milliards d'euros
une aide destinée à faire redémarrer
l'économie et notamment à favoriser
l'investissement privé à hauteur de 90
milliards d'euros et le renforcement de
certaines actions comme la création d'un
programme pour la santé c'est à dire
d'une certaine façon
l'ouverture n'ont pas de nouvelles
compétences mais à de nouveaux champs
qui sont indispensables à l'échelle
européenne si nous voulons là encore
tenir compte de ce qui s'est passé
la répartition entre les prêts les dons
questions que vous avez évoqué est
surtout fonction de la finalité de la
dépense un soutien la solvabilité d'une
entreprise sera également sera
généralement après les réhaussement du
feader ou du fse seront eux beaucoup
plus facilement des transferts
budgétaires
il n'y a là rien que de très logique
vous avez évoqué monsieur le député
bourlanges les risques des marécages
décisionnel européen et où je vous avais
dit des méandres aussi peut-être enfin
bref d'un d'un terrain qui ne serait pas
solide et sur lequel on peinerait à
construire un déficit d'1 édifice pardon
un édifice durable je me permets de vous
faire remarquer monsieur le député que
la france avait soutenu la proposition
du commissaire européen
moscovici tendant à utiliser la clause
passerelle pour justement faire passer
en matière fiscale les décisions n'ont
pas l'unanimité enfin de l'unanimité
vers la majorité qualifiée cette
position me semble devoir être maintenue
si nous voulons avancer il faut
effectivement changé de registre changé
de nature
conserver l'ambition mais s'en donner
les moyens merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole est un monsieur
gabriel serville
monsieur le premier ministre madame la
ministre et autres merdes
je salue la décision de sagesse de
reporter le second tour des élections
municipales de la nuit aisne qui vient
de passer au stade 3 de l'épidémie de
covile 19 conséquence d'une gestion
jacobine et aveugle aux réalités locales
de la part des autorités sanitaires
aujourd'hui nous en payons le prix fort
aussi quelle ne fut notre surprise
dimanche d'assister à l'exercice d'auto
satisfecit du président de la république
en total décalage avec la défiance
généralisée exprimé à son égard depuis
le début de la crise comment se
satisfaire de l'absence totale
d'anticipation et d'une gestion qui a
abandonné les populations et les
territoires les plus fragiles
d'ailleurs mayotte la guyane où la seine
saint denis en sont les premières
victimes
en réalité cette gestion a révélé une
politique qui a accouché d'un système de
santé exemple au sein d'une société
rongée par les inégalités qui découlent
d'une économie soumise aux logiques
financières
pourtant le président de la république
nous a indiqué vouloir nouveau chemin
mais les actes posés dans ces domaines
sont inquiétants car nous ne
construirons pas une société plus juste
sans contribution des plus puissants
la solution ce n'est pas de faire
travailler plus les français est loin
d'avoir appris des erreurs de la crise
de 2008
on fonce droit vers plus d'austérité -
de solidarité moins d'écologie et moins
de social ce n'est pas ce qu'attendent
nos concitoyens
c'est pourquoi je dis notre groupe
défendra ici même des propositions pour
venir en aide aux étudiants renforcer
les droits des salariés et surtout
reconstruire l'hôpital
dans ce contexte les mêmes erreurs
entraînant des conséquences identiques
la guyane et mayotte se retrouve de
nouveau en queue de peloton sanitaires
pourtant dès le 18 février
j'alerte est ici même sur l'urgence de
solutions adaptées au contexte guyanais
sur le plan géographique sanitaires et
sociales
nos territoires ont désormais besoin
d'un véritable plan de prévention et de
protection renforcée contre la copie 19
conformément à l'avis numéro 7 du
conseil scientifique monsieur le premier
ministre madame l'habilité outre mer
comment pouvez-vous vous
gage et je vous en remercie merci je
prenne la parole était valable indique
jardin ministre les autres moeurs
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
servile la guyane a connu ses premiers
premier cas ils ont été recensés début
mars vous saviez c'était des retours de
mulhouse et dès le début nous avons
appris des mesures des mesures fortes
confinement d'abord immédiatement
restriction des vols ensuite mi mars
augmentation des capacités sanitaires
livraison de plus d'un million de
masques et aux tomates bien sûr de
biologie par exemple l'hôpital de
cayenne vient d'augmenter sa capacité de
tests façon de 220 à une capacité de 400
tests par jour ces mesures ont donc
porté leurs fruits et vous le savez le
nombre de cas étaient très limitées
jusqu'à la mi mai et puis si la guyane
aujourd'hui connaît une situation
épidémique difficile avec plus de 1300
26 cas c'est en raison de sa proximité
avec le brésil qui subit une crise sans
précédent avec près de 900 mille cas
aujourd'hui et 44 mille décès alors
quelle est la situation qu'est ce que
nous avons fait eh bien on a mis en
place un contrôle strict des frontières
tout en aidant nos voisins de la mapa on
a mis en place des contrôles sanitaires
et des restrictions de déplacement sur
le principal axe routier pour éviter
effectivement que l'épidémie touche
touche l'ouest du pays maintenue un
confinement ciblées de certaines
communes de l'ouest guyanais et de
certains quartiers vous le savez
maintenu également un couvre-feu
actuellement effectifs dans 17 communes
de 21h à 5h du matin la totalité du
week-end à partir de 19h à cayenne
laisser les écoles fermées on a suspendu
les transports collectifs interdit les
rassemblements religieux et puis à ce
jour les lits de réanimation des centres
hospitaliers de guyane sont occupés à
50%
vous le savez on l'avait annoncé la
capacité totale sur le territoire et de
60 lits nous n'y sommes pas encore et
tant mieux
nous avons également travaillé un plan
d'évacuation sanitaire sur les antilles
et on a renforcé le personnel soignant
en mobilisant la réserve sanitaire
nationale
et en continuant à faire fonctionner
bien sûr l'ensemble des des hôpitaux
vous pouvez pas dire le député de
mayotte et de la guyane et vous le savez
la dernière information a été donnée aux
ministres la parole monsieur maxime
minots merci monsieur le président
messieurs le premier ministre aux termes
de l'article 12 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen seule la
force juste et consciente de sa mission
permet de faire reculer la loi du plus
fort les scènes de guérilla urbaine à
dijon et pas que ces derniers jours nous
le rappelle avec force un texte qu'il
faut rappeler à tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui nous tendent le piège du
communautarisme et d'une nation morcelé
divisé est donc affaibli un texte qu'il
nous faut aussi rappeler à ceux y
compris dans cet hémicycle qui montre
une complaisance coupable ou qui
pratiquent à l'envi la politique de l'
excuses à l'égard de ceux qui au passé
parfois douteux accable nos forces de
l'ordre oui il nous faut soutenir nos
forces de l'ordre car il n'y a pas de
liberté sans sécurité de même que la
république ne peut exister sans ordre
public
oui il nous faut soutenir nos forces de
l'ordre ces héros du quotidien qui font
un travail difficile dans des conditions
souvent extrêmes
oui il nous faut soutenir nos forces de
l'ordre en ne prenant pas des décisions
guider par l'émotion d'une infime
minorité de l'opinion publique
non nous ne pouvons pas tous les
condamnés pour les erreurs inacceptables
de quelques-uns non nous ne pouvons pas
accepter qu'il soit méprisé stigmatiser
violente et alors que les provocations
sont renforcées par une capitulation
moral au plus haut sommet de l'état
conduisant à une rupture consommée entre
ministre de l'intérieur et les forces de
l'ordre n'ont elles ne sont pas l'ennemi
bien au contraire elles méritent notre
respect notre reconnaissance et surtout
notre confiance
alors que la parole présidentielle n'a
pas été assez ferme en ce dimanche soir
comme de nombreux français je garde en
mémoire non sans une certaine émotion
les applaudissements au lendemain des
attentats terroristes
n'était-il pas destiné à ces mêmes
forces de l'ordre aujourd'hui cloué au
pilori médiatique
monsieur le premier ministre il ya des
ambiguïtés sémantique qui sont des
lâchetés politique ni si con mais pas et
affirmer sans réserve votre soutien
et ce qui nous protège merci monsieur le
député la parole est un monsieur
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs député monsieur le
député minots vous avez raison nous
devons à nos forces de sécurité cet
engagement et je n'ai jamais jamais
cessé de le porter de l'incarner et de
les défendre et à vous écouter je
n'accepte pas je voulais dit que l'on
insinue que j'aurais pu abandonner un
quelconque moment nos forces de l'ordre
moi qui étais chaque jour chaque nuit
depuis 20 mois à leurs côtés moi je n'ai
jamais eu de complaisance mesdames
messieurs les députés pour ceux qui
tentaient d'incendier une préfecture et
minimisé les violences dont ont été
victimes les forces de l'ordre moi j'ai
été à chaque fois présent à leurs côtés
quand ils ont été blessés insulter
stigmatisés et nous devons mesdames
messieurs les députés nous retrouver
tous ensemble à leur côté comme nous le
faisons chaque jour avec laurent nunez
mais comme nous le faisons quand nous
présentons un budget que vous n'avez pas
voté qui permet une augmentation des
moyens pour notre sécurité d'un milliard
d'euros
quand je fais en sorte que sur chaque
fiche de paye des gardiennes la paix ou
dégradés il est connu en 2019 une
augmentation située entre 130 et 140
euros net par mois
c'est cela monsieur le député la
reconnaissance de leur action la
reconnaissance de leur engagement
ce ne sont pas des mots qui vont qui
viennent et qui s'oublie parce qu'il est
essentiel monsieur le député vous avez
raison d'avoir de la mémoire parce que
beaucoup dans cet hémicycle et dont le
jeu politique confond de mémoire courte
avec bonne conscience alors comme j'ai
un tout petit peu de mémoire monsieur le
député je me souviens aussi de la
réalité de l'engagement politique du
groupe politique auquel vous appartenez
quand ce groupe politique a supprimé 12
mille cinq cents emplois dans la police
et dans la gendarmerie dans ce groupe
politique n'a pas su faire face au
paiement des heures supplémentaires
eh bien monsieur le député l'hon
de la police et de les défendre et nous
le faisons par des budgets par des
embauches
et même si ces messieurs merci monsieur
le ministre un peu de calme en écoute
malabo la forte za qui a la parole et
elle seule de la parole japonais
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
21 8 % c'est le taux de chômage des
actifs de moins de 25 ans 32,6 pour ceux
n'ayant pas le bac en poche
ce taux pourrait monter encore de 10
pour de 10 points dans les prochaines
semaines les moins de 25 ans seront les
premières victimes de la crise qui
s'ouvre il y aura bien une génération
qu'ovide une génération qui entrera avec
difficulté dans la vie active puisque
d'un plan de relance c'est d'un plant
d'existence dont nous avons besoin pour
donner tous les moyens à nos jeunes de
se réaliser
comment se relancer quand on n'est même
pas lancé dans la vie un plan
d'existence cette jeunesse le réclament
avec ces mots parfois ses colères de la
souffrance danas simulant le 8 novembre
dernier à lyon aux dizaines de milliers
de jeunes lycéens engagés pour le climat
en passant par les jeunes femmes battant
le pavé contre les violences sexuelles
et tout récemment la jeunesse des
banlieues qui se lèvent contre le
racisme et les discriminations
tous demandent de la justice réclame de
la dignité expriment leurs envies de
solidarité leur soif d'espérance ce
grand plan d'existence doit passer par
des mesures concrètes pour les sept cent
mille jeunes entrants sur le marché du
travail
quels dispositifs souhaitez vous porter
nous proposons notamment que les stages
soient rémunérés dès le premier jour de
travail
nous souhaitons aussi que la garantie
jeunes soient élargies et prolongé pour
celles et ceux en fin de droits
quels dispositifs d'urgence comptez-vous
mettre en place pour les jobs d'été qui
permettent aux étudiants de constituer
leur épargne pour l'année qui vient
à la rentrée allez vous maintenir l'aide
de 200 euros aux étudiants les plus
précaires pour ceux qui ne sont ni
étudiant ni dans l'emploi seriez vous
favorable à l'expérimentation d'un
revenu de
pas pour les jeunes entre 18 25 ans afin
d'éviter la trappe à pauvreté
monsieur le premier ministre qu'y at il
de plus précieux que notre jeunesse nous
avons le devoir impérieux de faire en
sorte qu'elle le sache et qu'elles en
soient fiers
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur gabriel a tall secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la député
aho la forte à dimanche soir le
président de la république dans son
intervention a fait de la jeunesse la
grande cause de la relance du pays parce
que la situation l'exigent
parce que sept cent mille jeunes doivent
rentrer sur le marché du travail cette
année parce que plusieurs centaines de
milliers de jeunes vous recherchez un
apprentissage parce que peut-être
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
jeunes vont se retrouver dans une
précarité supplémentaires à la rentrée
notamment s'agissant des étudiants vous
avez dit madame la députée il y aura
bien une génération qu'ovide je ne sais
pas s'il y aura une génération qu'ovide
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas de génération
sacrifiée
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que le
sens de l'intervention du président de
la république c'est de dire que nous
allons faire de la jeunesse le coeur de
la relance pas seulement pour réparer ou
pour empêcher les risques en matière
économique pour les jeunes mais pour
faire des jeunes le coeur de la relance
de notre pays parce que les entreprises
parce que les secteurs d'avenir dans
lesquelles nous allons investir auront
besoin des jeunes de leur créativité de
leur dynamisme et de leur mobilisation
parce que nous aurons besoin de jeunes
engagés auprès nos associations auprès
des plus vulnérables pour protéger
l'environnement à travers le service
civique à travers le service national
universel alors nous avons commencé à
agir avec jean michel blanquer sur la
question du décrochage scolaire
notamment dans la voie professionnelle
avec muriel pénicaud sur la question de
l'apprentissage avec des mesures
extrêmement fortes et nous allons
continuer à agir avec bruno le maire
avec mes collègues du gouvernement pour
inciter les entreprises à recruter des
jeunes pour développer les possibles en
matière d'emploi pour accompagner aussi
les jeunes qui seront dans la précarité
et s'il est un point sur lequel je veux
vous rassurer par rapport à votre
question c'est que nous accompagneront
les jeunes qui sont dans des situations
de rupture nous accompagneront les
jeunes qui connaîtront une précarité
supplémentaires et nous avons pour cela
de formidable dispositif que vous avez
cités notamment
la garantie jeunes ou le passé à pouvez
compter sur notre mobilisation et des
annonces seront faites dans les
prochaines semaines sur masson merci
monsieur le ministre la parole comme
monsieur régis juanico
merci monsieur le président messieurs le
premier ministre êtes vous oui ou non
favorable à la création d'un fonds
d'indemnisation pour les victimes les
plus graves du coronavirus comme nous le
proposons avec mon collègue christian
hutin et l'ensemble du groupe socialiste
et apparentés dans la proposition de loi
que nous venons de déposer ce fonds
permettrait d'indemniser toutes les
personnes connaissant des séquelles
temporaire ou définitive et les ayants
droits des personnes décédées du fait de
leur infection au virus
sarr skov deux sur le territoire de la
république française
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
a annoncé ici même le 21 avril une
reconnaissance systématique de maladies
professionnelles pour les personnels
soignants malades de lakovic 19
cette reconnaissance pour les seuls
personnels soignants qui manifestent
aujourd'hui est certes indispensable
mais n'est pas suffisante
elle exclut les personnels non soignant
de l'hôpital
toutes les autres catégories de
travailleurs les premiers de trancher
est monté au front pendant la crise
sanitaire et qui devront se soumettre
aux procédures classiques de
reconnaissance de maladie
professionnelle particulièrement
complexe longue et incertaine
elle ne concerne donc pas les hôtesses
de caisse les agents des forces de
l'ordre et de la sécurité les pompiers
les enseignants les agents de la
propreté publique ou de maintenance
les postiers les livreurs elle ne couvre
pas les résidents des ehpad les
bénévoles de la réserve sanitaire venus
prêter main forte à l'hôpital ou assurer
l'aide des plus démunis ni les
personnels et les personnes chargées de
la tenue des bureaux de vote lors des
élections municipales du 15 mars
si beaucoup de combattants en première
ligne ou en deuxième ligne
infectés par le sar ce kof deux ongs et
rient de forme moins grave de la maladie
d'autres sont décédés ou ont passé des
jours voire des semaines entières en
réanimation sous respirateur artificiel
et porteront des séquelles durables
ce fonds qui s'inspire de celui de
l'amiante ou des pesticides n'oubliera
aucun des malades atteints des formes
graves du corona virus et apportera une
réponse digne juste et rapide monsieur
le premier ministre
nous vous proposons de passer de la
parole et des applaudissements aux actes
en prévoyant l'indemnisation de
l'ensemble des préjudices subis sans
distinction de toutes les victimes
graves de cette pandémie si le ferez
vous la parole est à monsieur laurent
pietrowski secrétaire d'état chargé de
la protection de la santé des salariés
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député régis juanico dont je
voudrais prendre quelques instants pour
remercier de votre question elle fait
écho d'ailleurs à une proposition de loi
qui est porté par vos collègues du
groupe socialiste au sénat
je pense que sur le fond ce ce rappel ne
peut pas beaucoup vous générez le sujet
que vous évoquez c'est celui de
l'indemnisation des travailleurs fera
atteint du comique 19 dans le cadre de
leur activité professionnelle
et effectivement c'est un sujet
d'importance le ministre olivier ferrand
a pris un engagement le 23 mars dernier
et sa promesse sera tenue
vous le savez nous avons un devoir faire
en sorte que tous les soignants ayant
contracté le kovy de 19 après avoir
soigné des patients atteints puisse
obtenir une reconnaissance de maladie
professionnelle et obtenir une
indemnisation en cas de séquelles ou
malheureusement de décès pour les autres
travailleurs que vous évoquez au
monsieur le député qui ont pu être
contaminées dans le cadre de leur
activité professionnelle
nous allons faire aussi en sorte qu'il
puisse obtenir une indemnisation au
titre de la maladie professionnelle donc
je ne partage pas votre proposition de
créer un fonds
je crois qu'il est logique d'inscrire
cela dans le système de baladi
professionnels qui est déjà éprouvée et
qui fonctionne bien et qui me paraît
tout à fait adaptée à la problématique
que vous évoquez c'est-à-dire
l'indemnisation des travailleurs exposés
tous ceux qui ont composé la deuxième
ligne que vous pouvez évoquer d'ailleurs
monsieur députés car je crois que ce que
nous voulons tous c'est de voir tout
cela transforme et concrètement et
madame la ministre du travail
sur ce sujet et nous présenterons dans
les jours qui viennent les décrets qui
seront publiés ensuite très rapidement
sur ce sujet merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame jeanine dubié
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé l'idée d'un
cinquième risque ou de la création d'une
cinquième branche pour financer le
soutien à l'autonomie alimentent nos
débats depuis de nombreuses années
depuis 1988 lors dès 1988 lors de la
création de la csg par michel rocard la
création d'un cinquième risque était
déjà évoquée depuis le sujet a souvent
été abordé mais jamais traitée dans sa
complétude car chaque fois son coût
était jugé trop important pour les
finances publiques
hier soir nous avons débattu des
prémices d'une nouvelle branche au sein
du régime de sécurité sociale ayant pour
objet la prise en charge des dépenses de
soutien de tous nos mii des personnes
âgées ou en situation de handicap dans
les faits nous avons adapté le cadre de
financement de la loi de financement de
sécurité sociale et inscrire le principe
d'une nouvelle branche sans en
déterminer ni le périmètre ni le
financement et en l'étant aucun
financement supplémentaire n'est prévu
avant 2024
pourtant nous avons été nombreux à
relever qu'il fallait un financement
pérenne dès 2021 pour abonder cette
nouvelle branche et répondre aux besoins
des établissements et services que la
crise couve ils disent ne pas révéler de
façon dramatique
nous avons fait des propositions en ce
sens sans succès nous renvoyant
constamment au prochain plfss et à la
conférence des financeurs pourtant
pendant les débats monsieur le ministre
de la santé nous a annoncé qu'un
milliard d'euros supplémentaire
viendrait abonder cette nouvelle branche
ma question est donc la suivante comment
vous financer ce milliard supplémentaire
et surtout à quoi va être destinée cette
somme les attentes sont nombreuses
création de nouveaux postes en
établissement revalorisation des
salaires reconnaissance du secteur de
l'aide à domicile revalorisation des
prestations monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous lever les incertitudes qui
persistent a pris nos débats sur les
projets de loi adoptés hier et nous dire
à quelle échéance le projet de loi grand
âge et autonomie sera
cris à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée car si j'ai bien compris c'est
lui qui définira l'organisation le
périmètre et la gouvernance de cette mer
si mal jaser volonté la parole d'un
monsieur de réattaquer secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des solidarités de la
santé merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
là la députée avant de vous répondre
précisément effectivement rappelé que
cette nuit nous avons franchi une étape
que je qualifierais d'historique au sein
de cette assemblée vous en faisiez
partie vous avez participé au débat
puisque vous vous l'avais répété depuis
de nombreuses années depuis 2007 sur le
parti de droite de cet hémicycle la
réforme de la dépendance la création de
ce cinquième risque avait été promis en
2012 sur la partie gauche de cet
hémicycle la création d'un cinquième
risque avait été promis en 2020
l'histoire retiendra que cette majorité
aura créé ce nouveau risque et cette
nouvelle branche de la sécurité sociale
vous pouvez en être fier alors oui ce
risque est les modalités de financement
devront désormais faire l'objet de
concertation avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes fondations ont été posées
suffit maintenant il convient maintenant
de penser à la maison elle même c'est à
dire à quelles politiques publiques
nous voulons inscrire dans cette
création de 5ème branche r la
concertation avec les collectivités
territoriales les représentants du
secteur a débuté la semaine dernière
avec pour objectif global de préserver
le libre choix des aînés jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à la fin de leur vie les grands
objets de cette concertation sont connus
je me permet de les rappeler une
ambition forte pour l'accompagnement
elles sont à domicile
un changement de modèle des ehpad pour
en faire de vrais lieux de vie mais
adapté aux besoins les plus lourds un
soutien résolu au développement d'une
troisième voie avec ses solutions
d'habitat partagé ces petites unités de
vie à taille humaine mais du doter d'un
véritable accompagnement et une ambition
aussi évidemment pour les métiers du
grand âge dans la continuité du rapport
de myriam el khomri mhz alors le premier
ministre a annoncé une conférence de
financement va être organisée qui devra
rendre ses conclusions d'ici septembre
afin que cela puisse être intégré dans
le projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale quel autre texte
mieux que le projet de la finance de
financement de la sécurité sociale
pour parler de financement et oui d'ici
la fin de l'année un projet de loi sur
le grand âge sera inscrit au conseil
sera présenté excusez mon conseil des
militaires c'est y sera l'occasion de
discuter l'ensemble des asperges et le
ministre la parole de monsieur olivier
dessous merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
après le confinement nous rêvions d'une
france libérée mobiliser volontaires
encouragé par la reconstruction d'un
temps perdu nous espérions une communion
nationale
surmontant ses inhibitions fier des
soutiers de la gloire pour reprendre
cette si belle expression de pierre
brossolette
nous souhaitions un monde d'après plus
responsable plus serein plus harmonieux
heureux de retourner au travail de se
rendre au marché dans les parcs et aux
terrasses de café que reste-t-il de
l'inric tous un destin effondré des
châtiments publique victor schoelcher où
le général de gaulle et partisan roman
national tombent les uns après les
autres sous les coups des censeurs d'une
épurations éthiques
jusqu'où le laisserez-vous faire ce
combat sans nuance et cette exhibition
sans décence
l' angoisse des images la violence des
mots la suspicion des uns contre les
autres
s'ajoutait la fragilité des instants à
la crise économique sans précédent qui
fuit sur le quotidien des français la
perfusion financière injectés dans
l'économie ne suffira pas si les
tensions s'exacerbent
alors dans ces factures vous avez
sculpter la police et la gendarmerie en
boucs émissaires les attentats de
charlie hebdo ont ils été oublié la mort
héroïque du colonel bertram ignoré et
tous les autres morts ou blessés sous
l'uniforme
pendant ce temps la délinquance frottent
les mains
parce que la république se bandent les
yeux le pouvoir est affaibli
lafleur la france à fleur de peau les
relents âcre du passé s'immisce dans le
présent que restera-t-il si vous cédez
au retranchement
et comptez vous réaffirmer les valeurs
de la république et faire acte
d'autorité pour protéger et servir la
nation
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci merci monsieur le
président merci mesdames messieurs le
député monsieur le député d'assaut
permettez moi parce qu'on entend dans la
première partie de votre question le
plaisir des mots donc un techo font très
peu qui les ai commenté élus les miens
ceux de lundi dernier quand justement
comme vous j'avais des mots de soutien
d'engagement d'admiration et de fierté
pour la police pour la gendarmerie pour
nos forces de sécurité intérieure voilà
la réalité des mots que j'ai commis
lundi dernier et je vous le dit monsieur
le député ceux qui ont écouté mes mots
plutôt que les commenter n'ont pu y voir
ni lâchage ni jamais non plus absence de
courage parce que ce qui est essentiel
monsieur le député c'est effectivement
de regarder la réalité en face d'une
société qui vit dans des tensions et ces
tensions que certains exploitent sans
cesse et que nous devons combattre
nous avons des adversaires communs ici
ce sont ceux qui en veulent à la
république ce qui va le faire tomber la
république et nous devons monsieur le
député effectivement tous nous mobiliser
et les gardiens les gardiens des valeurs
de la république
ce sont les policiers ce sont les
gendarmes et ce sont nos militaires à
l'international comme sur le territoire
national ce sont eux qui effectivement
sont les garants de cette sécurité de
cette liberté absolument essentiel mais
il est essentiel aussi que s'il n'y a
pas de lâchage
il n'y a pas non plus d'abandons
d'autorité il appartient monsieur le
député au ministre de l'intérieur de
porter ce devoir d'autorité cette
exigence d'autorité cette exigence
d'éthique de morale et de responsabilité
dont je sais que je peux la demande et
aux forces de sécurité intérieure
parce que je vis avec eux au quotidien
depuis 20 mois et que je sais qu'en
aucun cas le collectif
l'institution ne porterait à mal la
réalité de cette éthique
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre c'est nous
plaît peut-être monsieur le ministre
mais pourquoi les forces de l'ordre
manifeste elle pourquoi les forces de la
médicale sont aux portes du palais cet
après-midi alors une seule chose entre
possible un possible de l'être un état
d'esprit rssi le hall l'avait bien vu
la parole est à monsieur plus de reprise
de ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur
il s'appelait clarissa jean-philippe
ahmed merabet jessica schneider jean
baptiste salvin xavier juge l'est arnaud
beltrame il s'était engagé pour servir
notre pays
assurer notre sécurité et garantir nos
libertés ils sont morts pour la france
parce qu'ils étaient policiers et
gendarmes
monsieur le ministre il vous aura suffi
de quelques mots lapidaires pour trahir
honteusement la mémoire de ces héros
français vous avez trahis humiliés
l'ensemble des policiers en décrétant la
tolérance zéro uniquement pour les
forces de l'ordre etes-vous le premier
flic de france où le protecteur des
délinquants vous avez jeté l'opprobe sur
les femmes et les hommes que vous êtes
censés protéger en ouvrant l'ère funeste
du soupçons avérés
etes-vous le premier flic de france où
l'avocat du millionnaire exilés
omer-sarraut mars haye
vous avez désarmés et les garants de la
paix civile
en voulant le retirer sans concertation
la technique de l'étranglement pourtant
réputée sûre et la plus efficace
etes-vous le premier film de france où
le porte-parole de mathieu kassovitz
vous avez fourni des armes morales et
judiciaires à la voyoucratie
à l'heure où centaines de tchétchènes
armes et déclenché de guerre civile à
dijon etes-vous le premier flic de
france où le représentant des zones de
non droit vous êtes soumis aux traoré et
aux revendications antirépublicaine et
violente
si quelques permanences de député en
marche vous faisait hurler à nathan vous
se faisait hurler à l'attentât vous ne
dites rien
pour dénoncer fermement les 110
agressions que subissent chaque jour nos
policiers gendarmes et pompiers alors
qu'un policier se suicident les cinq
jours dans notre pays vous tolérez des
manifestations racialiste interdite où
l'on crie ça juifs en appelant à
balancer des flics dans la seine comme
monsieur le ministre allez vous enfin
partir merci monsieur le député la
parole est à monsieur christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
bild
je ne laisserai pas le débat sans fermer
entre ceux qui haïssent la police et
ceux qui au fond des voix des luttes
légitimes des défenses légitime pour
mieux endormir demain et vous fait
partie aussi de cette catégorie
je veux vous dire et je veux dire à tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui expriment des
colères expriment des colères dans des
luttes légitimes qu'il doit être
protégée y compris dans les
manifestations par les forces de
sécurité intérieures mais que nous
devons respect et protection à nos
forces de sécurité intérieure et je vous
le dit monsieur le député notre police à
chaque instant est à pied d'oeuvre
contre le terrorisme contre les trafics
contre la délinquance contre le racisme
et les discriminations
la semaine dernière j'ai reçu les
syndicats de police et j'ai écrit aux
policiers et j'ai porté cette exigence
cette ambition de combat contre le
racisme
il n'est pas question de stigmatiser la
police nationale
quand nous combattons le racisme en son
sein parce que quelques individus et
seulement quelques individus la salisse
par leur comportement au contraire c'est
parce que l'on veut défendre la police
nationale que l'on doit porter cette
exigence sur tous les fronts d'une
tolérance ray 0 contre le racisme
il n'est pas question monsieur le député
de désarmer nos forces de l'ordre quand
il s'agit de leur proposer une autre
technique d'interpellations quand vous
êtes ministre monsieur le député et
qu'un groupe de travail présidé par le
directeur général de l'agencé nationale
et le directeur général de la police
nationale vous fait une proto nisation
arrêté un geste dangereux parce que ce
geste
non seulement on peut commettre des
dommages irréparables au moment de
l'interpellation mais peut avoir des
conséquences sur toute la vie la
carrière du policier acquis au monde a
appris veut faire ce geste dans son
engagement professionnel et donc oui les
protéger c'est aussi mieux les former
c'est leur donner des outils pour éviter
justement qu'ils se retrouvent demain
devant des magistrats
et c'est en cela monsieur le député que
je suis fier de les défendre ministre la
parole est à monsieur pierre yves
bournazel
merci beaucoup monsieur le président ces
derniers jours un vent mauvais souffle
dans notre pays
d'un côté ceux qui affichent un
nationalisme obsidionale à la recherche
perpétuelle de bouc émissaire le
nationalisme c'est la ségrégation et la
division de notre société c'est à dire
le contraire du sentiment national et de
la république
de l'autre côté ceux qui prônent le
séparatisme qui attisent les haines au
sein de notre société et qui n'hésite
pas à véhiculer l'antisémitisme au vent
mauvais comme l'a rappelé le président
dimanche la république est forte elle
est forte parce qu'elle parle à toutes
les femmes et à tous les hommes sans
distinction d'origine et de condition
sociale
la république c'est l'état de droit
c'est l'égalité des chances et des
droits c'est un appel à la justice c'est
la liberté c'est la dignité de la
personne humaine
oui il y à du racisme dans notre société
oui il y à de l'antisémitisme oui la
haine de l'autre en fonction de ce qu'il
est est un poison citoyens et élus du
xviiie arrondissement de paris
je mesure l'indignation et la colère que
cela peut engendrer
mais je sais aussi que c'est là dans ces
quartiers que le besoin de sécurité et
le plus prégnant la police républicaine
assure des missions difficiles
un lien de confiance doit être tissés
avec chaque citoyen les policiers sont
des héros du quotidien et nous devons
les soutenir en améliorant sans cesse
leurs conditions de travail
ne cédons jamais à la division notre
pays a été trop facturés dans le passé
la république nous unit elle nous permet
de faire société et nation le
gouvernement oeuvre
pour abattre les cloisons jeunesse école
logement formation emploi culture
partout il faut continuer à investir
pour que les valeurs de la république se
traduisent toujours plus en actes je
m'adresse ce gouvernement répondra le
ministre qu'il souhaite la mise qui
souhaitent qu'elle initiative compte
prendre le gouvernement pour faire vivre
l'amour et le service de la république
merci j'ai un collègue la parole est à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames ciel du petit monsieur le
député bournazel merci merci de votre
propos d'un propos qui défend ce qui
fait la république ce qui fait notre
commun ce qui nous appartient à tous et
qui implique effectivement des forces de
sécurité intérieure pour défendre ce
commun le commun c'est ce qui nous
rassemble c'est ce qui permet de se
regrouper
c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
retrouvés tous ensemble derrière la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité et donc
il est hors de question
comme vous l'avez dénoncez vous aussi
donner c'est ce débat sans fermer entre
ceux qui d'un côté haïssent la police et
des voix d'élus jet team et ceux qui au
fond veulent toujours trahir notre
république
nous avons besoin d'un ordre d'un ordre
juste d'un ordre incarné par nos forces
de sécurité intérieure nous avons besoin
au fond que ceux qui manifestent contre
le racisme comprennent que ils
trouveront chaque jour chaque nuit comme
premier combattant à leurs côtés contre
le racisme
les forces de sécurité intérieures parce
que chaque fois qu'elles sont appelées
chaque minute chaque seconde
elles répondent présents elles sont
mobilisés pour appliquer notamment les
lois que vous avez voté et récemment
celle qui permet de signaler tout acte
tout propos antisémites racistes
homophobes et d'intervenir plus vite
encore là encore ce sont des policiers
ce sont des gendarmes qui répondent
présents notre police chacun le sait est
toujours mobilisée toujours à l'action
mais nous devons aller plus loin tous
ensemble porter ce pacte républicain
incarner ce pacte républicain et
s'implique ce lien entre la police la
gendarmerie entre la sécurité nous
citoyens je n'ai pas attendu les débats
actuels pour faire cela dès le mois de
janvier
j'ai réuni une convention citoyenne avec
une centaine de personnes
de tous les quartiers de france de
toutes les horizons pour pendant deux
week-ends de jours travaillés avec les
forces de sécurité intérieure pour
conforter ce lien essentiel
quelques fois abîmée par des campagnes
médiatiques ou des propos excessifs que
l'on peut entendre dans cet hémicycle et
je vous remercie monsieur le député
d'avoir voulu être à la hauteur de ce
débat et à ne jamais chercher à le
caricaturer
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur eric coquerel
merci cette question est à l'attention
de monsieur miss de la santé chère
collègue nos soignants nos soignantes
ont travaillé sans relâche durant
l'épidémie de kobe 19 beaucoup en ont
été atteints trop et y ont laissé leur
vie
le 16 mars emmanuel macron avait déclaré
nous leur devons évidemment les moyens
la protection on sait aujourd'hui que
beaucoup se sont retrouvés avec des sacs
poubelles pour ce l'armure le 14 avril
le président disait aussi notre pays
aujourd'hui tient tout entier sur des
femmes et des hommes que nos économies
reconnaissent et rémunère mal mais le
gouvernement a dû nous cacher les notes
de bas de page de ses discours lénifiant
car nos héros d'hier sont aujourd'hui en
salles d'attentes les mois passent et on
ne voit venir ni plus de reconnaissance
ni de meilleures rémunérations pire vous
semble expliquer désormais au soignantes
et aux soignants qu'ils devront
travailler plus en remettant en question
les 35 heures pour gagner plus vous
aviez pourtant premier de vous
réinventez qu'attendez vous donc ce
serait pourtant si simple d'écouter les
soignantes et les soignants pour une
fois rien qu'une fois
voilà des mois voire des années qui vous
répète avec espoir les mêmes
revendications celles qui les amène
encore devant l'assemblée aujourd'hui
par dizaines de milliers revaloriser les
salaires et mieux reconnaître les
qualifications mettre en place des plans
de formation et de recrutement massif
dans les hôpitaux et les ehpad renforcer
les moyens des établissements arrêté
d'en fermer rouvrir des services et
délit arrêter de lanterner le temps
presse votre ségur n'a rien de sûr
ecoutez-le est plutôt que de reparler de
responsabiliser ou donner plus
d'autonomie à l'hôpital public ce qui a
été pendant des années synonyme
d'austérité et donc de continuer à le
tuer les soignants ne veulent pas
les commerciaux ou les vrp de votre
start up d'ascione ils veulent prendre
soin de leur patient et avoir les moyens
de les traiter dignement de ne pas avoir
que cinq minutes par douch de ne pas
avoir à compter le prix de chaque
transfusion quand allez-vous les
entendre quand allez-vous agir
attendez vous que la prochaine vague
épidémique frappe un système de santé
sans plus de moyens merci monsieur le
député la parole ça me chagrine attaqué
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député coquerel
la manifestation de ce jour que vous
évoquez dans votre propos est le symbole
de la tente des soignants
celle ci est évidemment totalement
compréhensible elle l'était dès avant
l'épidémie elle l'est plus encore depuis
la grande mobilisation de ces dernières
semaines de ces derniers jours pour
lutter contre le coc vident leur
impatience est grande
votre impatience est grande elle l'est
tout autant de notre côté
devant l'inaction les errements de ces
vingt dernières années dans
l'organisation de notre système de soins
alors oui aujourd'hui notre politique de
santé doit être à la hauteur de nos
soignants nous devons tenir compte à la
fois de la crise que traverse l'hôpital
public depuis plusieurs années de la
formidable résistance du système de
santé face au coc u19 et de toutes ces
lourdeurs dont il a été nécessaire de se
débarrasser pour sauver des vies alors
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont été très clair il y
aura un engagement de l'état sur les
rémunérations des soignants au delà des
primes qui ont d'ores et déjà été
engagées à l'issue de cette crise un
plan massif d'investissements et de
revalorisation de l'ensemble des
carrières sera construit pour notre
hôpital mais il faut aussi de l'autre
côté nous donner les moyens de trouver
des solutions pour transformer notre
système de soins dans son ensemble aux
côtés de l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'hôpital du médico social de la ville
oui ça fait des années mais pour la
première fois nous allons prendre
l'ensemble de l'hôpital de la ville et
du médico-social ans rencontrée je suis
assez étonné de vous entendre dire que
la question de l'autonomie et de la
gouvernance des hôpitaux ne serait un
non sujet puisqu'il est question
justement d'associer davantage les
soignants à la gouvernance des hôpitaux
l'ambition est importante le calendrier
est serré vous l'avez dit mais sachez
que dans le cadre du ségur de la santé
ce sont plus d'une centaine de réunions
qui ont eu lieu depuis le lancement de
ce secure sous l'égide de nicole notât
ce sont plusieurs dizaines de réunions
qui ont lieu dans les territoires ce
sont près de quatre vingt mille
consultations qui ont lu à travers de la
plate forme que nous avons mises en
place nous serons au rendez vous de la
réforme de notre système de santé
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur michel herbillon août
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé est
alors qu'aujourd'hui en france les
personnels soignants manifeste je tiens
à leur adresser la reconnaissance de
tous les députés les républicains
monsieur le ministre je souhaite vous
interroger sur la situation de nos aînés
dans les ehpad qui est particulièrement
douloureuse avec les collègues de mon
groupe
nous n'avons cessé de vous alerter tout
au long de la crise sanitaire est de
vous faire part de notre inquiétude pour
celles et ceux qui se sont trouvés
de fait coupé du monde outre l' angoisse
de la maladie et la crainte de la mort
s'est rajouté depuis le 11 mars
le poids de la solitude et de
l'isolément avec l'interdiction pour
deux aînés de voir leurs enfants et
leurs familles
nombre d'entre eux sont même victimes de
ce terrible syndrome du glissement qui
leur ôte tout goût à la vie vous aviez
annoncé des allègements à compter du 5
juin pour autoriser les visites mais vos
annonces au niveau national ont hélas
été suivi de peu d'effets sur le terrain
nous avons tous été saisis dans nos
circonscriptions par de nombreuses
familles qui n'ont pas pu voir leurs
parents depuis trois longs mois
maintenant
c'est dire s'il annonce du président de
la république dimanche soir autorisant
enfin les visites étaient attendus
pourtant elle suscite encore beaucoup de
scepticisme tant les familles ont été
échaudés ces dernières semaines monsieur
le ministre
pouvez-vous nous garantir que les
visites dans les ehpad sont bien
effective partout en france depuis hier
pouvez vous nous assurez
que tout en préservant bien sûr les
règles de sécurité sanitaire les
familles peuvent dès maintenant voir
leurs parents dans leur chambre et que
les résidents peuvent désormais sortir
de leur établissement avec leurs proches
allez vous monsieur le ministre donné
des instructions claires en ce sens afin
qu'il ne faille pas attendre encore de
longues semaines pour que ces mesures
entrent en vigueur et ne soit pas dévoyé
par des réglementations locales
il y a aujourd'hui urgence car le moral
de nos aînés au plus bas il y a urgence
à ce que désormais notre société leur
porte l'attention si et l'affection
qu'ils méritent de recevoir
c'est une question me dis jamais avec la
parole que monsieur adrien taquet
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
je peux vous garantir une chose monsieur
le député c'est que la sécurité la santé
le bien-être aussi de nos aînés et la
seule boussole c'est la seule boussole
depuis le début de cette crise et ça le
reste
aujourd'hui je vais vous répondre très
concrètement le virus a beaucoup circulé
vous l'avez rappelé dans les ehpad et
cette circulation active a justifié le
recours à des mesures de 10,2
distanciation strictes aujourd'hui la
situation évolue le nombre de cas est en
diminution et nous permet d'engager une
nouvelle étape l'étape dont nous sortant
a été difficile à vivre on vous l'avait
dit pour nos aînés monsieur la bad pour
leurs enfants pour leurs petits enfants
également
alors concrètement cela signifie que
dans les établissements qui ne déclarent
plus de cas possibles ou confirmés de
colis de 19 les directeurs devront
établir d'ici la fin de la semaine d'ici
le 22 juin un plan de retour progressif
à la normale en concertation avec les
équipes soignantes et en particulier les
médecins coordinateurs
ces plans seront soumis obligatoirement
conseil de vie sociale
ces plans seront soumis au conseil de
vie sociale qui représente les résidents
et leurs familles ça vous pose problème
ça me semble totalement légitime
nous avons un impératif mais sur le
terrain monsieur le député sur le
terrain monsieur le député la situation
n'est pas la même
dans chacun des territoires et il est
normal il est légitime il est de notre
responsabilité de laisser à chaque
directeur d'établissement d'établir le
plan de retour à la normale qui est le
plus adapté à la situation locale et à
la santé à la sécurité des résidents
l'objectif
l'objectif mesdames et messieurs les
députés et d'assurer prioritairement le
plus vite possible
la reprise des visites des proches sans
rendez vous de façon progressive
faudrait autoriser la reprise des
sorties individuelles et collectives de
la vie sociale au sein de
l'établissement la fin du confinement en
chambre la reprise de l'ensemble des
interventions paramédical et aussi la
reprise des admissions en hébergement
permanent un document un nouveau jeu
terne monsieur le président un nouveau
document de cadrage sera publiée
aujourd'hui qui remplacera le précédent
pour fixer les nouvelles règles à mettre
en oeuvre dans les ehpad dans chacun des
établissements
merci monsieur le ministre bérengère
merci monsieur le président madame la
garde des sceaux nous ne connaissons que
trop ce chiffre une femme meurt sous les
violences de son conjoint ou ex conjoint
tous les deux ou trois jours
ces chiffres nous ont alertés
parlementaires de la majorité
nous sommes fortement mobilisée avec une
proposition de loi visant à protéger les
victimes de violences conjugales
traduisant les conclusions du grenelle
initiée par le premier ministre et la
secrétaire d'état marlène schiappa de
nombreuses avancées ont été voter la
levée du secret médical
la suspension du droit de visite et
d'hébergement interdiction de la
médiation saisi des armes ou encore la
lutte contre l'espionnage numérique
autant de mesures que je suis fier
d'avoir porté dans ce texte qui a été
adopté à l'unanimité le 9 juin dernier
au sénat signe d'un véritable consensus
qui amènera je l'espère à une cmp
conclusive afin de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre ces mesures attendues très
rapidement
chers collègues nous avions également
ici même voté dans la loi du 28 décembre
la possibilité de délivrer une
ordonnance de protection en six jours
nous connaissons tous ici l'importance
cruciale que représente ce dispositif
pour les victimes
seulement pour que ce délai de 6 jours
puisse être applicable il faut pour cela
respecter le principe du contradictoire
c'est-à-dire assurer aux défenses au
défendeur pardon un délai suffisant pour
faire valoir ses droits
le pire étant pour la victime
l'annulation de la procédure
vous avez pris un décret en ce sens
madame la ministre je sais que vous avez
à coeur et meilleure protection des
victimes
seulement ce décret a suscité de
nombreuses interrogations notamment des
associations des deux victimes
pour y répondre vous avez mis en place
un comité de pilotage avec les acteurs
concernés afin qu'une solution adaptée
puisse voir le jour
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre
j'aimerais que vous donniez des
précisions quant à l'avancée de ces
discussions relatives à ce décret je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole qu'à
madame nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
et si vous voulez bien ne criez pas ce
sera mieux
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames les députés messieurs
les députés madame la députée couillard
l'engagement du gouvernement vous le
savez dans la lutte contre les violences
conjugales est très fort et pérenne
il accompagne le vôtre depuis plusieurs
mois le chiffre toujours glaçant des
féminicides pardon semble connaître une
légère inflexion 36 féminicide depuis le
début de l'année 150 en 2019
ce chiffre là nous encourage à
poursuivre notre politique volontariste
et cette politique volontariste elle se
traduit par différentes mesures
au delà de celles que vous avez évoquées
qui figureront dans la proposition de
loi qui est en cours de débat
je citerai l'augmentation des téléphones
grave danger en un an nous sommes passés
de 300 à 1000
je citerai les circuits d'urgence dans
les juridictions pour mieux accompagner
les victimes
je citerai également parce que c'est
très important
l'éviction des conjoints violents et
notamment pendant cette période du coc
vide avec madame la secrétaire d'état à
l'égalité femmes hommes
nous avons pu financer une plate forme
d'hébergement des conjoints violents et
je citerai les ordonnances de protection
qui aujourd'hui sont délivrées au nombre
de 4000 ce n'est pas assez nous
souhaitons aller au delà
le parlement a voté vous l'avez rappelé
un texte qui encadre la délivrance de
ces ordonnances dans un délai de 6 jours
une fois le juge saisi nous avons pris
un décret d'application le 27 mai qui
tenait compte à la fois du principe du
contradictoire et de l'exigence de
délivrance ce décret a suscité des
inquiétudes et il m'appartenait d'y
remédier j'ai donc beaucoup discuté avec
les associations et nous sommes convenus
de prendre un certain nombre
d'évolutions
parmi elles l'accompagnement des
victimes tout au long de la procédure
l'aide juridictionnelle
le passage de l'assignation de 24 heures
à 48 heures et la fin de la caducité il
me semble que ces éléments qui
trouveront leurs traductions dans le
décret qui sera rectifiée en ce sens
nous permettront d'apaiser des
inquiétudes et de conforter notre seul
objectif commun lutter contre les
violences conjugales
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie et d'un ami nice pour
ces précisions parlementaires de la
majorité nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à ce que ce décret soit
favorable aux victimes mais aussi nous
serons vigilants à ce que le délai de 6
jours votée par le parlement puisse être
respecté
merci le canada manuela clébard mon
désir ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'économie
monsieur le ministre vous connaissez
l'importance de l'octroi de mer pour les
collectivités d'outre-mer se doit
d'autogestion et des libertés locales
auxquelles nous tenons le président de
la république à plusieurs reprises a
manifesté son attachement au système de
l'octroi de mer se félicitant à la
réunion en octobre dernier que ce
système protège la production locale
avec des exonérations et des taux très
bas pour la production locale une part
de ça de ce produit finance nos
collectivités locales
c'est aussi un outil décentralisée de
bonne gestion puisque ces taux sont
fixés par les collectivités régionales
en fonction des besoins
il faut le garder affirmait le président
de la république il ne faut surtout pas
le bouger
on a besoin de préserver sa stabilité
disait-il madame la ministre des autres
maires a confirmé cette volonté devant
la délégation aux autres maires à
l'assemblée nationale disons que
et apportera à nouveau le sujet de
l'octroi de mer dans les mêmes
conditions que précédemment auprès de la
commission européenne
or voici que le 25 mars en pleine crise
sanitaire
la fondation pour les études et
recherches sur le développement
international a publié un rapport sur
l'impact économique de l'octroi de mer
dans les départements d'outre-mer
français à la demande du ministre de
l'économie qui préconise sa suppression
consternation outre l'école est unique
européenne n'a jamais préconisé de
renoncer à la production à la protection
de la production locale les élus
d'outre-mer ne peuvent évidemment se
souscrire à cette volonté économique de
terre brûlée qui souligne encore une
fois la méconnaissance grave des
réalités ultramarines suivre les
conclusions être ultra libérale des
rapporteurs ferait disparaître et les
finances locales et la production locale
avec des conséquences inacceptables
la question est donc simple allez vous
défendre l'octroi de mer à bruxelles
cautionné vous un tel rapport merci mme
le député la parole thomas d'avant dj
varda ministre d outre mer le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée qui est clairement désire
vous l'avais dit dans votre question
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de répondre aux
députés ultramarins à l'ensemble de la
délégation de l'outre-mer de l'assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet ce rapport c'est
un rapport macroéconomiques
c'est loin d'être le premier c'est loin
d'être le dernier sur la question de
l'octroi de mer et moi je pense vraiment
madame la députée que y'a pas de mal à
s'interroger sur un outil et je lui ai
déjà dit il était intéressant qu'on se
pose la question tous ensemble de
l'avenir de l'autre en mer mais j'ai
aussi dit devant vous tous pas
aujourd'hui pas en sortant de cette
crise pas sans que les territoires
ultramarins me le demande
et c'est l'ensemble de la vie du
gouvernement mais encore une fois je
crois que il est bon de savoir que si le
sujet n'est pas celui du jour eh bien
nous aurons un jour à nouveau posée et
puis la récente annonce du gouvernement
aux côtés des collectivités
territoriales
hamon sur la compensation de notre anr
fait par le premier ministre le 29 mai
dernier vous montre combien
effectivement le gouvernement est engagé
aux côtés des collectivités notamment
par cette annonce de compensation de
l'autre anne mère et donc je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire que le gouvernement
penserait éventuellement à remettre en
cause cet outil aujourd'hui ni
d'ailleurs c'est la difficulté à
accepter cette remarque sur la
méconnaissance des outre mer cet
engagement du premier ministre comme de
l'ensemble du gouvernement côtés des
collectivités et je regarde ma collègue
jacqueline gourault qui se bat pour les
mêmes choses et bien c'est un engagement
auprès des communes de leurs groupements
un engagement aussi aux côtés des
régions ultra ultra marines et une
spécificité de venir compenser la
totalité de des pertes d'octroi de mer
ou de taxes sur les carburants
ça va être calculée sur les trois
dernières années c'est une mesure
historique ses 160 millions évalué
aujourd'hui mais nous aurons l'occasion
de faire le point avec l'ensemble des
collectivités
et puis ben oui la france ira défendre
le régime
oprah mr à bruxelles et je m'engage à
paroles de monsieur christophe lejeune
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre le troisième projet
de loi de finances rectificative qui a
été présenté la semaine dernière en
conseil des ministres traduit une partie
des mesures que vous allez mettre en
oeuvre pour protéger les emplois et
accès accéléré la transformation
industrielle et écologique de notre pays
avec ce plan de soutien exceptionnel
vous au qu'accompagner par ailleurs les
collectivités territoriales dans leur
gestion de la crise au plus près du
terrain à travers un plan inédit de 4,5
milliards d'euros pour les aider à faire
face aux conséquences économiques et
sociales du coc vite 19
il s'agit d'un soutien massif et inédit
au bloc communal et au département
il reprend un grand nombre des
propositions de la note d'étape rendu
par vos collègues jean rené cazeneuve
si le choix du gouvernement depuis 2010
set a été celui de la stabilit
tu es et de la maîtrise ce qui a permis
aux collectivités d'affronter en bonne
santé par des finances locales scène ces
circonstances exceptionnelles
vous avez décidé d'aller beaucoup plus
loin certaines communes auront à
craindre une diminution de leurs
recettes domaniales en raison de l'arrêt
brutal de l'activité économique
et je pense aussi à toutes les communes
forestières particulièrement à celles de
mon département de la haute-saône donc
pour la plupart le budget dépend en
grande partie de leurs ventes de bois et
qui se retrouveront en difficulté à la
suite de la baisse d'activité de la
filière alors même que la forêt
française
plus que jamais essentielle à notre
économie et à notre environnement c'est
notre patrimoine vivant
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
détailler avec précision les différentes
mesures inscrites dans ce projet de loi
de finances rectificative et la manière
dont les collectivités seront associés
au plan de relance national à coup sûr
en préservant leurs recettes
nous préserverons la commande publique
locale et tout le tissu économique de
proximité
elle est très nombreuses en merci hugo
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur le député christophe
lejeune vous avez rappelé le plan de
relance et le plan d'urgence et de
soutien au bloc communal aux
départements et aux régions d'outre-mer
concernant l'octroi de mer justement
pour garantir leurs recettes fiscales
et vous avez raison de dire qu'il est
inédit jamais un plan de cette nature
n'a existé
vous avez cité également la nécessaire
préservation de la commande publique
c'est pourquoi le premier ministre
annoncée il ya dix jours que la dotation
de soutien à l'investissement local la
fameuse décide serait abondé d'un
milliard d'euros dès 2020 ce montant je
le rappelle vient s'ajouter aux deux
milliards déjà inscrit deux des terres
et deux aces de décines dans le budget
est maintenue bien sûr sans faillir
depuis trois ans j'insiste sur le
calendrier bien sur 7
ce supplément de dotation d'un milliard
d'euros sera bien inscrit dans le plf r3
vous insisté par ailleurs sur les
communes forestières
bien entendu elles font partie de notre
préoccupation et nous savons qu'elles
ont des investissements à faire et je
m'engage à soutenir
bien sûr les communes forestières dans
leurs investissements nécessaires et par
ailleurs je ne doute pas que madame la
députée anne laure quatre lots dans le
cadre de la mission qui lui a été
confiée par le premier ministre sur la
forêt et le bois face au changement
climatique sera attentive à cette
question des recettes et permettra de
contribuer à des pistes de réflexion sur
la problématique de valorisation de la
filière bois
ce rapport vous savez sera remis cet été
bien entendu nos efforts ne s'arrête pas
là nous avons aussi le débat sur 2021 et
les années suivantes au plf qui va
commencer bientôt puisqu'on est déjà en
réflexion
nous ne laisserons pas nos collectivités
et tous les niveaux de collectivités
j'insiste sur le bord du chemin
car ensemble nous devons assumer la
relance de notre pays ministre la parole
est à monsieur xavier breton
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
selon vous quels sont les sujets
prioritaires auxquels le président de la
république le gouvernement et le
parlement doivent se consacrer dans les
12 prochains mois
à cette question posée par l'ifop pour
le collectif marchon enfants dans un
sondage paru hier
la réponse des français et sans
ambiguïté et elle est finalement de bon
sens et trois priorités sont la
sauvegarde de l'emploi le pouvoir
d'achat
l'efficacité de notre système de santé
viennent juste derrière la sécurité la
protection de l'environnement où
l'avenir de notre système de retraite
puis d'autres sujets et à la toute
dernière place se trouve relégué
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
pour les femmes seules et pour les
couples de femmes
avec 1 % de réponses un seul % de nos
compatriotes considèrent le sujet de la
pma comme prioritaires
faut-il que ce tout petit pour cent soit
1 furent pour que vous cédiez à la
pression qu'ils exercent et que vous
décidiez de réinscrire l'examen du
projet de loi de bioéthique
dès ce mois de juin en commission et dès
le début du mois de juillet dans
l'hémicycle monsieur le premier ministre
alors que notre pays affronte une crise
sanitaire majeure alors que la crise
économique s'annonce très douloureuse
pour des millions de nos compatriotes
dans les mois à venir alors que des
tensions embrase chaque nuit nos villes
et nos quartiers vous décidé de rallumer
dans notre pays un foyer de contestation
pourtant plus de sept français sur dix
71% exactement estiment que ce projet de
loi doit être suspendu et même retiré
pour donner la priorité à la gestion des
conséquences de la crise ducobu de 19
alors quel malin plaisir trouvez-vous a
soufflé sur les braises
monsieur le premier ministre nous
déplorons chaque jour la fracturation de
notre société dans une surenchère de
polémique et dans un engrenage ans qui
est inquiétant de violence alors est-ce
faire preuve de responsabilité que de
poser avec ce texte les français les uns
contre les autres
monsieur le premier ministre pour quoi
diviser notre pays sur un sujet qui
n'est ni prioritaire ni urgent alors
prions tous et au congrès être mobilisés
solidaire par la salle à monsieur adrien
taquet secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des solidarités de la centimes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
xavier breton pouvait pas réduire les
lois de bioéthique est la seule
assistance médicale à la procréation
même si c'est une avancée majeure
attendue par des dizaines des centaines
de milliers de femmes dans notre dans
notre pays je vous rappelle qu' à la
question de l'accès aux origines pour
les enfants nés dans le secret ou encore
des avancées considérables pour la
recherche sur l'embryon notamment alors
oui oui monsieur le député la loi de
bioéthique porte de nombreuses inventé
sociétal c'est un texte qui est attendu
par nos concitoyens par des familles par
des enfants bien sûr mais aussi des
chercheurs des scientifiques et il est
essentiel que la navette se poursuivre
ses débats ce texte ces débats ont
commencé depuis un an déjà vous en avez
été un des acteurs majeurs me souviens
des débats que nous avons pu avoir dans
cet hémicycle avec madame la garde des
sceaux avec
buzeins à l'époque et je salue votre
engagement je pense que chacun sur ses
bancs plus reconnaître que ce débat en
première lecture que ce soit ici ou au
sénat a été un débat serein un débat
riche un débat respectueux des positions
de chacun loin des caricatures que
certains voulaient parfois portait alors
le gouvernement ait fait le choix il a
été salué par tous de ne pas engager la
procédure accélérée
à l'époque cela signifie que nous
prenons le temps du débat mais aussi que
plusieurs lectures seront nécessaires
avant l'adoption définitive du projet de
loi
plus qu'un autre texte ces lois de
bioéthique ne peuvent se contenter de
délégations de voeux tous deux ou de
consignes de groupe
et d'ailleurs je me souviens bien qu'au
sein de votre groupe même entre vous et
monsieur mignot par exemple vous aviez
des positions différentes mines au
pardon excusez moi monsieur le député
mais non maximino parce que ses
questions interroge l'intime de chacun
sur ce texte il est impératif que chacun
puisse s'exprimer
cela a été confirmé en conférence des
présidents monsieur le président ce
matin à partir du lundi 22 juin tous les
députés pourront siéger dans l'hémicycle
à condition de porter un masque
dès lors tout le monde peut exprimer sa
position et nous aurons le plaisir de
nous retrouver en commission puis dans
cet hémicycle pour poursuivre l'examen
de ce beau projet de loi qui arrive le
ministre la parole à monsieur jean paul
mattei
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur les listes de
l'action et des comptes publics je
voudrais associer à cette question mais
que l'aigle josy poeyto et erwan
balanant monsieur le ministre la crise
économique que nous traversons sera
particulièrement dur et impactante pour
les plus fragiles d'entre nous alors que
depuis le début de ce quinquennat le
taux de chômage était descendu à 8,1
pour cent soit le plus bas niveau depuis
la crise de 2008 le nombre des
demandeurs d'emploi est amenée à
connaître une forte hausse dans les
prochains mois il nous revient plus que
jamais de prévoir les mesures
d'amortissement nécessaires pour la
reprise l'activité économique
à cet égard les entreprises ou
associations d'insertion par l'activité
économique présente une solution adaptée
aux populations les plus éloignés de
l'emploi
mais ces 4000 acteurs qui accompagne
près de deux cent cinquante mille
personnes par an sont fragilisés en
raison de l'incompatibilité des aides à
l'embauché qu'ils versent aux employeurs
et que chômage partiel
la crise du coc vide va impacter ses
entreprises à hauteur de 30 % de perte
d'activité une baisse de 27%
le chiffre d'affaires vingt mille
parcours d'insertion sont menacés ces
entreprises associations devraient
pourtant bénéficié cette année de 200
millions d'euros de crédits votés en loi
de finances
dans le cadre du plan gouvernemental de
développement de l'insertion annoncé en
septembre dernier
elles craignent le gel de ces crédits
est réglable déblocage de ces fonds qui
leur permettrait de pouvoir poursuivre
leur mission
aussi monsieur le ministre pourriez vous
nous indiquer quelles dispositions sont
prévues par le gouvernement pour se
tenir les acteurs de l'insertion par
l'activité économique
les crédits votés en plf à cet effet
seront ils débloquer rapidement et
j'insiste sur le terme rapidement
allez vous modifier le régime
d'attribution des subventions que ces
acteurs gère pour l'adapter à la
situation économique je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur laurent prêtre pietrasinski
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
protection de la santé des salariés
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean paul mattei
vous avez raison d'attirer l'attention
du gouvernement sur l'insertion par
l'activité économique parce
qu'effectivement c'est un élément
fondateur de notre politique d'ailleurs
de lutte contre le chômage depuis plus
de trois ans d'ailleurs dans le cadre du
renforcement de des objectifs que nous
avons pour l'iae il ya nous avons vous
savez mobiliser un grand nombre de
ressources puisque en 2020 c'est plus
d'un milliard d'euros qui a été mobilisé
pour lee a alors vous m'interrogez sur
sur le fond ce que sera le devenir de
tous ses acteurs après cette crise
sanitaire et dans cette crise économique
que nous vivons
d'abord rappelé que le gouvernement a
décidé d'investir massivement depuis
plus de trois ans je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure mais c'est parce que cela
fonctionne parce que vous même vous
l'avez vu et vous en
et le témoin et vous avez souhaité ici
partager avec la représentation
nationale
votre conviction en la matière et j'ai
eu encore récemment des échanges avec
des écossais la député marceau qui
rappelait la réalité de l'agilité de
l'ensemble de ces sociétés qui
travaillent par l'insertion et qui ont
redéployé leurs activités notamment pour
certains et certaines ont se lançant
dans la fabrication de masques récemment
ou en tous les cas en trouvant des
nouveaux débouchés car la réalité c'est
que aussi l'ensemble de ces acteurs sont
pénalisés par l'évolution de notre
économie pour tenir compte des
circonstances exceptionnelles et
sécuriser les parcours nous avons ouvert
je voudrais lui rappeler monsieur le
député le recours à l'activité partielle
au siao est autorisée aussi les
renouvellements de contrats des salariés
en insertion placé en activité partielle
je tiens même à préciser que ces
contrats pourront désormais être
prolongée jusqu'à 36 mois contre 24
actuellement et pour terminer monsieur
le président juste rappeler que des
mesures de soutien supplémentaires que
vous avez évoqué destiné à consolider le
secteur suite à la crise seront bien
mise en place à l'été et cela sera
l'occasion d'un échange avec la parole
merci monsieur le président durant le
confinement nos applaudissements chaque
soir sont allés au soignant à l'hôpital
dans leurs cabinets à domicile ils ont
donné sans compter mais aujourd'hui est
pour eux une journée de mobilisation
pour être enfin entendus
et même s'ils nous disent qu'ils n'ont
fait que leur travail
la nation la nation à une dette vis à
vis de cette dette c'est leur donner
plus de moyens matériels et humains pour
bien travailler cette dette s'est
amélioré leur rémunération chaque mois
cette dette c'est tenir les engagements
qui avaient été pris par votre
gouvernement sur le versement des primes
alors les personnels
hospitaliers et des pad la recevront
très bien même si ce ne sera pas du même
montant pour tout le monde mais la
grande inconnue
elle concerne les aides à domicile
l'état et les départements se renvoient
la balle pour savoir qui financera
monsieur le ministre de la santé les
aides à domicile souvent des femmes qui
touchent de petits revenus avec des
conditions de travail difficiles eh bien
ces aides à domicile ne peuvent pas être
les otages les otages d'une discussion
entre l'état et les collectivités
locales
monsieur le ministre de la santé quand
les aides à domicile recevront tél
cette prime cette reconnaissance que la
nation leur doit merci chers collègues
la parole à monsieur adrien taquet
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député garot un
témoin de m'associer tout d'abord à vous
pour rendre hommage de soignants qu'ils
soient de l'hôpital du domicile et des
ehpad mais il est toujours bon de leur
dire monsieur le député car bien sûr
l'implication des personnels des
services à domicile n'a jamais été en
doutez vous parler des primes et je
tiens à rappeler ce qui a été acté
l'assurance maladie prendra en charge le
versement pour tous les établissements
et services tarifés par l'assurance
maladie y compris lorsque celle ci n'est
pas le tarificateur unique
ce mécanisme conduit les services de
soins infirmiers à domicile a bénéficié
de la prime car ils sont concernés par
le versement par l'assurance maladie
les services d'aidé d'accompagnement à
domicile
quant à eux ne sont pas tarifé par
l'assurance maladie mais par les
conseils départementaux vous l'avez
évoqué le versement de la prime leur
revient donc car cela fait partie
intégrante de leur compétence de la
responsabilité top comme tout comme pour
les travailleurs sociaux de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance par exemple et à
titre d'exemple hier soir le conseil
départemental de meurthe-et-moselle a
indiqué qu'il va débloquer 2,2 millions
d'euros pour financer cette prime
exceptionnelle à destination des
personnels des services d'aidé et
d'accompagnement à domicile et je ne
doute pas qu'il en sera bientôt de même
en mayenne si tel n'est pas encore le
cas
en meurthe et moselle ce sont 2000 aides
à domicile qui vont recevoir jusqu'à
1500 euros de prime
s'agissant des ehpad c'était une
promesse du gouvernement que de
reconnaître l'engagement et
l'investissement sans faille de ses
personnels
le décret est sorti en fin de semaine
c'est une prime de 1000 euros pour tous
les professionnels qui sont employés par
un ehpad qu'il soit médicaux ou non
médicaux qu'ils soient titulaires
contractuels ou apprentis vous savez que
dans 40 départements qui ont été
particulièrement exposés aux que vide
cette prime est majorée à 1500 euros
elle peut être versée dès le mois de
juin par les employeurs s'ils l'avancé
le remboursement par l'assurance-maladie
interviendra pour les établissements
financiers ou co financé dès juillet
nous parlons bien je conclurai par là
d'un dispositif exceptionnel qui se fait
en parallèle du cadre de la serrure de
la santé ou le gouvernement s'est engagé
à une revalorisation des carrières et
des compétences et les parcours les
professionnels de l'hôpital mais les
messieurs le député de la pomme
président si je comprends bien monsieur
le ministre l'état prend des engagements
fait des promesses que les départements
vont devoir financer honoré ensuite je
vous le dit monsieur le ministre vous
avez semé de la déception vous allez
semé de l'injustice et vous ne
récolterait que de la colère c'est
monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur emmanuel maquet
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances le projet de loi de
finances rectificatif numéro 3 met en
oeuvre un certain nombre de plans de
soutiens sectoriels pour le tourisme ou
l'automobile l'aéronautique ou encore la
technologie
toutes ces mesures de relance sont
évidemment les bienvenues pour protéger
ses secteurs clés de notre économie
impacté vous le savez par la crise du
coït 19 pour autant en adoptant une
approche sectorielle vous laisser de
côté un certain nombre d'industries
moins importante par le nombre d' usine
mais stratégique pour l'emploi sur nos
territoires des industries primordiale
au niveau local mais que vous n'estimez
pas assez stratégique au niveau national
pour susciter votre intervention
à l'image de la classe moyenne trop
riche pour être aidés mais pas assez
pour se projeter sereinement dans
l'avenir cette industrie de pointe est
prise entre la baisse historique
d'activité
un état qui préfèrent regarder ailleurs
c'est le cas de l'industrie verrière
chez moi dans la somme localisé dans la
glass vallée qui fédère 70 entreprises
représentant dix mille emplois
spécialisés et plus de soixante dix pour
cent de la production mondiale de
flacons de luxe c'est une filière
d'excellence monsieur le ministre ou le
savoir faire et la technologie de haute
précision de nos industriels font le
succès des parfumeurs du monde entier
aux gars de la baisse de la demande
internationale dans les cosmétiques et
la parfumerie les industriels de la
glass vallée me disent à quel point ils
redoutent le moment où la dégressivité
du chômage partiel imposera une
adaptation des effectifs
bien évidemment si l'activité ne
redémarre pas monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas aux salariés de payer les
conséquences d'une crise sanitaire qui
aurait d'ailleurs été moins sévère si on
l'avait mieux gérer alors ma question
est la suivante
que prévoyez-vous pour accompagner cette
industrie de luxe qui appartient à l'adn
de la france et les milliers d'emplois
qui l'accompagnent face à la crise la
plus grave de son histoire
si je colle avec la parole est à
monsieur bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie et des finances et monsieur
le président monsieur le député mckay je
veux vous rassurer
nous ne laisserons tomber aucun secteur
industriel est certainement pas celui de
la glass vallée chère à mon coeur est
cher au coeur du premier ministre
puisque la vallée de la bresle est un
lieu d'excellence normand de cette glace
valait que vous connaissez bien et que
nous connaissons bien nous avons d'abord
pris un certain nombre de mesures pour
sauver l'emploi dans le secteur
industriel toutes les mesures de chômage
partiel ont bénéficié massivement au
secteur industriel et notamment la glass
vallée pour lui permettre de garder ces
emplois et de garder ses compétences
nous avons fait ensuite le choix qui
sera celui de la loi de finances qui
sera présenté en juillet et discuter ici
au parlement de soutenir les secteurs
qui sont les plus immédiatement menacé
avec des centaines de milliers d'emplois
qui sont en jeu c'est l'aéronautique
c'est l'industrie automobile c'est des
secteurs avec leurs sous traitance
sur lesquels aujourd'hui les enjeux sont
absolument immédiat nous aurons
l'occasion et le président la république
l'a dit dans son intervention de
dimanche soir de prendre des mesures
structurelles pour renforcer nos choix
en matière industrielle à partir de la
rentrée
je pense en particulier à tout ce qui a
trait à la compétitivité du secteur
je pense ce qui a trait aux impôts de
production qui sont indispensables si
nous voulons rester attractif et faire
en sorte qu'une entreprise soit
compétitive je pense à tout ce qui a
trait à la formation à la qualification
je pense à tous ces secteurs qui sont
des secteurs d'excellence dans lequel la
glass vallée peut parfaitement
s'inscrire qui font que nous ferons
absolument tout pour préserver l'emploi
industriel de notre pays et je vais vous
dire une conviction quand on regarde les
résultats que nous avions obtenu avant
la crise avec la relance de l'activité
industrielle
la reconquête industrielle sur votre
territoire comme sur tous les
territoires français
quand je vois que nous avions été
capables pour la première fois depuis
dix ans de recréer enfin des emplois
industriels et des sites industriels en
france
quand je vois qu'aujourd'hui sanofi
investi 600 millions d'euros pour créer
une usine de vaccins dans notre
territoire c'est possible et nous allons
y arriver
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances madame la ministre
la crise de sanitaires du colis de 19
inédite à bien des égards
de par sa force et son ampleur nous a
davantage convaincu de la nécessité pour
notre pays de disposer d'une industrie
médical souveraines capables de faire
face aux épidémies des plus virulentes
la recherche scientifique française a
été mise en lumière durant cette période
en termes de traitement comme de vaccins
en parallèle il est indispensable de
repenser notre stratégie nationale de
production de médicaments
le président de la république en visite
aujourd'hui dans une usine de production
de vaccins de l'entreprise sanofi pardon
dont un site de fabrication de
médicaments est installé dans ma
circonscription dans l'oise a d'ailleurs
rappelé dimanche l'ordre
son allocution la nécessité de
souveraineté des enjeux sanitaires et la
défense de notre pacte républicain
l'annoncent ce jour de 610 millions
d'euros d'investissements dans la
recherche et la production de vaccins en
france concrétise ses objectifs et nous
ne pouvons que collectivement nous en
réjouir unir nos forces prend tout son
sens et l'europe a pris conscience de
cet enjeu comme l'attestent la décision
de la commission européenne qui envisage
d'investir 10 milliards d'euros pour la
santé
cette indépendance de l'outil de
production et de l'approvisionnement
dans notre pays dont notre pays a besoin
passe par la reconstruction d'une
économie forte écologique solidaire
notamment par une relocalisation des
industries pharmaceutiques sur notre
territoire national et européen
dès lors madame la ministre quels moyens
ou dispositif prévoyez vous de mettre en
place pour répondre à ces enjeux
d'indépendance nationale et de
relocalisation deux autres de nos
industries stratégiques
merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame agnès pannier riz
relâché secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée bureau bonnart merci
pour cette question qui met
effectivement en lumière tout le travail
qui a été accompli par cette équipe
gouvernementale non seulement au service
de l'industrie et bruno le maire vient
de le rappeler mais plus précisément au
service de l'industrie pharmaceutique
car vous connaissez le constat le
constat c'est une perte de part de
marché de 50% entre 2008 et 2018 et
c'est sur cette base là qu'il nous a
fallu collectivement reconstruire
reconstruire au travers du comité
stratégique des industries de santé qui
dès 2018 a prévu un plan d'action sous
l'égide du président de la république et
du premier ministre pour reconquérir ray
attiré réimplanter des industries de
santé
mais c'est également dans le cadre de la
crise du coc vide que nous nous sommes
mobilisés mobilisé en travaillant sur
cet investissement investissements
massifs de sanofi qui va permettre non
seulement d'implanter un site pour les
vaccins mais un site qui puisse être
mobilisée en période de crise
un site qui puisse fabriquer en urgence
des vaccins comme nous sommes en train
d'y travailler maintenant avec olivier
ferrand avec frédéric vidal car il faut
anticiper des réponses possibles
sanitaires et on voit toute l'importance
d'avoir des sites en france capable de
fabriquer tous types de vaccins c'est ce
que nous faisons avec sanofi mais c'est
également la volonté de réimplanter des
productions en france des productions
sur les principes actifs nous y avions
commencé à y travailler avec sanofi des
productions sur les dispositifs médicaux
des productions également sur les
molécules mature car il n'y a pas que
l'innovation qu'il faut accompagner et
le tout en bonne intelligence avec
l'union européenne la commission
européenne il vous savez que nous
soutenons ce projet 10 pc hui
l'équivalent de la batterie électrique
européenne pour les industries de santé
nous allons donc réunir jeudi avec
olivier ferrand l'ensemble des
industriels de la santé pour leurs
projets leur proposer un plan d'action
de relocalisation accompagnées de moyens
et
nous aurons l'opportunité de renforcer
durablement un souveraineté industrielle
merci le ministre la parole est à
monsieur stéphane thiery merci merci
monsieur le président ma question je
vais adresser à monsieur pied travesti
parce que notre collègue matt et n'a pas
eu réponse à sa question pertinente
monsieur le ministre vous avez élu dé sa
question sur l'ia initialement faut-il
reconnaître que j'avais eu l'idée
d'interroger monsieur le ministre des
comptes publics mais je préfère in fine
et obtenir une réponse de votre part
eu égard à l'importance du sujet et je
veux parler des moyens alloués à la
politique de l'emploi
frappé par l'épidémie kobe 19 les 3800
entreprises ou associations de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
sont dans la tente d'un vaste plan de
relance afin de répondre à la crise à la
crise qu'elle traverse ce secteur qui
accompagne et vous le savez les publics
les plus fragiles celles et ceux qui
sont durablement douaniers de l'emploi
subit depuis cette crise comme nombre de
tpe et de pme de très lourdes pertes
d'activités leurs besoins en trésorerie
est immédiat et j'insiste monsieur le
ministre
leurs besoins en trésorerie est immédiat
vous avez évoqué qu'il y aurait des
annonces faites au cours de cet été
moi je considère et j'avais cru
comprendre que des mesures devaient être
annoncés incessamment sous peu
il ya quelques jours et je crois
comprendre qu'il y à des arbitrages sur
la porte et le contenu de votre plan qui
serait davantage prévu et qui
retarderait votre prise de décision ce
cas ce calendrier n'est pas tenable et
la méthode utilisée me paraît encore
moins tenable
il semblerait monsieur secrétaire d'état
que ce plan soit moyens budgétaires
constant sans soutien financier
ce ne serait donc pas un plan et pire
encore il se pourrait que la part non
dépensés du milliard d'euros prévus
cette année pour l'iae dans le budget du
ministère du travail soit ponctionné
dans cette hypothèse ce serait une faute
depuis plus de 30 ans l'iae est un
levier formidable
de retour à l'emploi on sait que cette
crise
essayez de nombreux femmes et hommes sur
le carreau vous ne pouvez pas réduire
les crédits de l'iae et vous ne pouvez
pas laisser le secteur sans réponse
immédiate face au fléau du chômage qui
s'annonce ne cédez pas aux pressions de
bercy tenez les arbitrages obtenu par
madame mais aussi lors du plf
merci monsieur le député la parole de
monsieur laurent pietrasinski sur
internet a changé la protection de la
santé des salariés
merci monsieur désormais de monsieur le
député monsieur député stephen fry
vous avez eu l'obligeance à la fois de
faire la question une partie de la
réponse tout en reconnaissant que
j'avais répondu au député mettez en
précisant que les dispositions seraient
prises à l'été mais ce que j'entends
dans votre question est peut-être en
cela vous fait écho à la question de
votre collègue vous voudriez que cela
aille plus vite et vous vous interrogez
sur le fond sur les dotations qui était
prévu des dotations au poste et ses
dotations qui ont été sous consommer de
par la nature même de la crise sanitaire
qui n'a pas permis à toutes ces
entreprises de développer l'ensemble de
l'insertion qu'elle avait prévu de faire
et bien cette réflexion sur ces
dotations fait partie des échanges que
mène effectivement madame la ministre du
travail dans le cadre de son activité de
sa mission et les arbitrages ne vont pas
tarder simplement ils sont en cours et
pour vous répondre eh bien il est mieux
de les connaître et pour cela qu'ils
aient été effectuées c'est pour ça que
je ne pouvais pas mieux me répondre
c'est l'après midi monsieur députés
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à madame rahmati ali merce
merci messieurs président madame la
ministre d outre-mer alors que toute la
france reprend son souffle après trois
mois de retenue
mayotte et la guyane dans une situation
préoccupante à l'échelle de leur
population
les deux territoires sont encore
répertoriés en sont orange la gestion de
la crise a été différente un hexagone en
raison des passerelles et de coopération
de la densité du territoire et du
maintien des échanges transfrontaliers
alors oui depuis paris nous pouvons bien
ma cheminée des denrées du matériel
médical
mais nous ne pouvons ni té la ressource
en eau lille l'emporté elle fait défaut
nous avons besoin d'eau pour respecter
scrupuleusement les recommandations
sanitaires et les gestes barrières et si
votre passage remarqué à mayotte le mois
dernier a permis grâce au pont aérien
établi d'apporter un souffle
l'heure est à l'établissement d'un plan
de sortie de crise pour le tour de
mesures pérennes
il en va donc de ma responsabilité de
réclamer notamment des mesures pour
accroître l'accès à l'eau sur mon
territoire
un plan équilibré et visionnaire sur le
long terme
nous avons des solutions nous avons
expérimenté l'implantation d'une usine
de désalinisation de l'eau de mer en
petite terre mais ces piscines ne peut
desservir que les communes avoisinantes
privant le reste de l'île de son
bénéfice extension en création d'une
usine nouvelle
cet investissement ne peut voir le jour
sans une contribution substantielle de
l'état tant sur le plan de l'ingénierie
que s'agissant du volet financier
je le répète la persistance du couvent
et 2 révèle bien qu'il y a urgence
sanitaire renforcée à mayotte
aussi permettez-moi de vous interroger
madame la ministre d'une part sur les
mesures prévues pour parvenir à une
sortie de crise sanitaire
d'autre part sur le soutien du
gouvernement en vue du développement de
structures alternatives pour combattre
la pénurie d'eau je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame annick girardin ministre d
outre-mer sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
ramat yali votre question est double
d'abord cela que la situation sanitaire
à mayotte et ensuite sur la question de
l'eau sur la question sanitaire à
mayotte en effet mayotte a été durement
touchée comme l'est aujourd'hui la
guyane et reste vous l'avais dit en zone
orange alors grâce à la mobilisation et
aujourd'hui on a une circulation du
virus qui malgré tout active mais qui
est en grande diminution et je crois
qu'il est important de son satisfaire
même s'il faut rester extrêmement
vigilant et voulez et vous le savez
pourquoi je le dis parce que tout
simplement depuis le 2 juin il n'y a pas
eu de placement en réanimation pour
détresse respiratoire liée aux qu'ovide
et puis le pic épidémique de co
circulation parce que mayotte avait une
co circulation de deux virus dingue plus
qu vide aurait été dépassée c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs que le gouvernement a
décidé d'organiser les élections
municipales à mayotte dans les semaines
qui viennent c'est d'ailleurs évidemment
le choix aussi que nous avons fait pour
venir apporter un nouveau plan de de
santé qui doit être finalisé dans les
jours qui viennent
suite à la mission de deux
épidémiologistes à mayotte qui était
venue lors lors de ma visite
voilà je voulais également vous dire que
sur la question de nous il est évident
que la crise sanitaire a accentué les
effets des difficultés de l'eau à
mayotte
eau et assainissement si je puis me
permettent de compléter
c'est un sujet de préoccupation
effectivement d'urgence mais aussi
majeur à court et à long terme le plan
d'avenir pour mayotte que j'ai
présentées vous le savez elles après la
crise mayotte en 2018 prévoit la
mobilisation de 67 millions d'euros en
faveur de l'eau et l'assainissement
sur ce la fin de ce quinquennat à
mayotte +2 6 mille mètres cube de
capacité de production journalière
supplémentaires d'eau potable ont été
ainsi autorisé et sont actuellement en
travaux durant la crise qu vite vous
l'avez dit l'état est intervenu pour
garantir un accès à l'eau minimal sur le
territoire notamment dans les quartiers
les plus les plus précaires j'ai
également demandé que les services
d'état accompagne les collectivités pour
que nous puissions faire plus
et autres rendez-vous la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance est suspendue